foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
to anyone
all around the world are you kidding me
the chess.com Global Championship offers
the dream of playing against the best
whoa and hey have we mentioned there's
also a million dollars at stake the
total pot is a million dollars know that
it's not a typo the prizes are
unbelievably generous we began with
thousands of players now only dozens
remain you you don't just do this to
chakra in a critical game except Alexis
Verona just did gorgeous chess he makes
his way into the round of 16.
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real
Judah on to the round of 16
trip to the cgc finals and a clean shot
at the largest first place prize of the
year
my friends it's the cgc round of 32. who
will take the next step to Toronto
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
2022 chess.com Global championship in
action-packed morning and we are here to
cover the afternoon shift we have three
Unforgettable matches for you I'm your
host Grandmaster Daniel narrative skill
alongside me today the one and only
Grandmaster Amman Hamilton I'm on good
afternoon to you three amazing matches
on the docket what more could we ask for
hey Dania hello to everybody watching I
am very excited to get into this
commentary today you called it we have
three super exciting matchups and I mean
when you you think of names like
carbonakamura yeah
napometian I mean these names on their
own are enough to be mouth-watering but
check out their opponents as well as the
a competition Narrows Dania I mean every
match just becomes so competitive and
although we have favorites we don't have
anything close to guarantees absolutely
not it narrows at nepos it's Fiddlers
nobody has had an easy go of it thus far
in the round of 64. not Hikaru Nakamura
not Levon aronian and now they're path
to Toronto become even more difficult
sicaro faces David Navara incredibly
strong Grand Master from the Czech
Republic it's nepo against svidler and
Lavon aronian faces multiple time RCC
weekend winner Maxi montlickoff and a
perennial annual super Grandmaster
incredibly solid player let's go through
these matches one by one starting of
course with the nepos Fiddler match Jana
pamishiaman is on fire whatever he
touches on the chessboard turns to gold
right now
yeah no nepo is having obviously a high
point in his career that's for sure he
recently has been absolutely dominant
and he's up against Fiddler who I think
is that that wild card for everybody
everyone knows just how talented Peter
is
um but he's been doing uh you know I
think I think Peter at this point is
just one of those players that nobody
wants to necessarily match up against
because they know how strong he is but
he's that little bit of a wild card so I
think Peter Fiddler is a player that has
that you know 2750 plus ability that he
just kind of he plays so casually so
effortlessly and I think he's a really
scary opponent for someone like nepo who
is in great form at the moment without
question that's like seeing Michael
Jordan in the park he might be you know
55 years old he hasn't played in the NBA
for 20 years Peter has been struggling
it's no secret he didn't do great in the
Fisher random tournament he hasn't done
as well in his last few over the board
tournaments but he still has the Super
Grand Master pedigree he's won the
Russian Super Final many times you don't
do any of that by accident it's going to
be a tough match for nepo and of course
it's going to be a tough match also for
Hikaru Nakamura David Navara a name that
I think most people in the chat have
probably at the very least heard of one
of the nicest people in the entire Chess
World a Class Act but also a fearsome
chess player who's been in and out of
the 2700 club for the better part of two
decades Amman yeah absolutely uh David
Navarro we remember his last match
against Michael Adams I don't think I've
ever seen an Armageddon be so one-sided
uh as he he took that match down
effortlessly uh with the black pieces as
well so David Navara you know he has
that uh demeanor like he's such a a
great nice guy and well he is but he's
also willing to stick it to you on the
chessboard as well Hikaru Nakamura a
clear favorite here Dania but when it
comes to navara's style Deacon
absolutely I mean he's a quick player he
he trusts himself he has his theory he
generally knows his game plan going in
so he trusts himself and he can play
quickly and he can keep up with Hikaru
on the clock now as for the moves that
remains to be seen he car was definitely
the favorite but don't sleep on this
match as Hikaru did not have a walk
through in his last match no very far
from it actually I mean it was a tie
match after game one he could have lost
game one against the Chilean Grandmaster
Rodrigo Vazquez so uh Hikaru isn't going
into this tournament thinking that you
know Toronto is guaranteed nothing is
guaranteed in the cgc that's why we're
watching and that's that is also why
we'll be watching the final of today's
matches levana Roni and last but not
least faces off against Maxine matlakov
aronian has been all over over the place
I'm on he's been playing everywhere
online over the board everything you
could pot rapid classical blindfold
Fisher random I mean he has had his
fingerprints over all of the top
tournaments he's 39 years old Lavon no
longer a spring chicken but he still
plays like he's in his teens he still
has that vibrancy that flamboyancy to
his style so you know Maxime is gonna
have to bring the kind of form that
enabled him to win some of the RCC
weekenders otherwise you've got no
chance against an in-form LeBron yeah
absolutely uh Lavonna Rooney and I feel
is uh definitely surging right now when
it comes to his his chest he's always
been at the top I mean he's a player
that if we look back on his chess career
he was well into the the 2800 uh
category like one of the highest rated
players in the world so Lavon has has
really been up and down but always been
in that top 10 of Chess and you say the
name of honoronian and he's right there
um Matt lakov on the other hand is a
name that might not be as familiar but
of course uh for players that are
familiar with the you know the Russian
higher league and these kind of really
serious tournaments and of course the
chess.com uh rapid events as well I mean
he's he's definitely a player that I
don't think aronian is going to feel as
an easy pairing or anything
um so I actually think that you know for
all these matches uh this match that we
we just talked about might actually be
one of the closest ones and I certainly
think it'll go to Armageddon
absolutely and we will be starting with
hikaranakamura we will take a look at
the community prediction shortly but
first let's take a look at the overall
bracket all 64 players 32 invites and 32
qualifiers are here a lot of them are
out a lot of them are in amazing form
we've seen some incredible displays thus
far linear Dominguez uh yesterday Alexi
Serrano put together a phenomenal match
to defeat chakra Ahmad yarov I feel like
I'm looking at the intro to Game of
Thrones where we see a map of the whole
Kingdom and you know there's the
Nakamura Kingdom over on the top left
and you know Jeffrey Zhang over in the
bottom left and as we zoom into the
brackets the individual kingdoms and
Nations we have sub-story lines them on
uh that sort of headline each individual
bracket this bracket of course features
the car Nakamura he is the one who has
the X on his back and uh who leniere
Dominguez is likeliest but not
guaranteed to face in the round of 16.
right as we have the you know the
brackets really start to shape up as
there's only a couple more spots to be
filled four to be exact and one of them
is uh right here hikaranakamura against
David Navara it could be the
All-American uh matchup
um coming up next and actually uh I
think you know most number one seeds are
actually advancing uh from what we've
seen in their respective groups and
another one of those is Yanda palmnushy
who you know made short work uh in the
past but now comes up against Pierce
Fiddler who's a lot uh you know more of
a formidable opponent than uh previously
but I just think uh Daniel the form and
the way that nepo is playing right now
is just it's too consistent yeah nobody
has been able to stop him I mean every
anything anybody throws at him uh just
fails miserably I mean his opening
preparation has been impeccable he has
honestly he's changed his style he's
changed his opening repertoire and all
of it has been for the better and
finally today we will be contesting also
the H bracket with Lavon aronian against
Maxine matlockoff to determine who will
be facing the talk about on form a Sam
Seville who defeated Rasmus Vain and
then who defeated mvl also in an
Armageddon and also in an absolutely
crushing display so these are the three
brackets that we will be contesting
today and finally before we jump into
the games let's take a look at the
community community predictions
predictions here where's the David
Navara fan club yeah it's uh well
there's 103 of them
um that yeah basically sums up what you
guys think about these uh these matchups
and well you know maybe these are a
little bit lopsided Dania but you have
to say you know Hikaru Nakamura yeah and
Lavon aronian uh three clear favorites
going into today I didn't expect that it
would be that much honestly we're we're
the Peters Fiddler fans like I guess
nepo has won a lot of people over lately
he really has 96 to four and I think
these predictions are fair but obviously
that is the nature of an upset you don't
think it's possible until it happens and
uh so far the community has been pretty
accurate in predicting the results of
the matches we've definitely had our
share of upsets I mean obviously Savvy
and MBL or shook us out so you know it's
in the air it's no question that is it's
in the air and it's incredibly important
for the favorites Aman to start with a
win in game one remember that it is a
four game match with a Time control of
15 plus two seat belts fastened
everybody we are about to begin I think
we will start with Hikaru Nakamura and
then the next matches will start a
couple of minutes after that
Hikaru he has to get get off to a better
start him on than he did against Rodrigo
Vazquez because David Navarre is going
to punish him
yeah that's the thing um but for those
that remember the last uh Hikaru
Nakamura match that um Dania and myself
called in this chess.com Global
Championship I don't think Hikaru can be
that careless and I think the person who
knows that most of all is Hikaru
Nakamura he probably didn't feel great
about that match especially the way it
started
um he could have been in more serious
trouble and a guy like David Navarro if
he gets an opportunity he knows what's
at stake here he knows how good Hikaru
is and if you keep giving the chances to
your opponents small uh mistakes you
know a guy like David Navarro he's gonna
pounce on it and the game has started
and already a change from Hikaru
Nakamura in comparison to game one
against Vazquez he basically goes for a
main line here he goes for a Mainline
nimso Indian E3 and Bishop D2 which is a
rather fashionable line that we have
seen in a high level chess recently so I
feel like David Navarro must have been
expecting what Hikaru has been doing
almost exclusively online Knight F3 B3
G3 and here we see sort of the Nakamura
Vault going for uh principled one D4
variations
yep and you know when we say that people
have prep when we use that word that
term
um there's a few different kinds of
preparation that a player can have this
for example what hikaru's played this
isn't what I would call dangerous prep
this isn't something where David Navarro
has to worry about being worse in a
couple moves or you know going down a
rabbit hole where Hikaru is going to
have this crazy computer line uh this
kind of prep is just you know oh I
generally know what kind of positions
I'm getting into
um you're probably going to be less
familiar uh you know from hikara's
perspective he's going to be more
comfortable he's going to know the plans
where the pieces go and it's an offbeat
line less common than you know what is
played generally lately and you know
it's a trendy line so it's still
developing not everything is figured out
yet and I tell you Dania if you look at
what's on the board right now if I was
like seeing a student of mine playing
this in a tournament I might say E3
Bishop D2 what what are you doing man
blocking in your Bishop this looks like
beginner stuff but actually it's very
high level yeah gold learn a proper line
of the nimso but a couple of years ago I
know Sam my friend Sam shankland uh
started playing he played it against me
and it's hard to take it seriously you
know the bishop on D2 kind of looks
awkward but the the main point of this
move is that in the nimso you frequently
see black capturing on C3 and here you
know white does not want to ruin his
Pawn structure white wants to recapture
with the bishop and what David Navarro
was thinking about is which setup he
wants to adopt like you're saying him on
it isn't this isn't about figuring out
how to equalize it's about figuring out
which type of position David Navarro
wants so the black pieces he goes for C5
now you could continue striking at the
center with D5 or the line that a lot of
top Grand Master shoes is to fee and
Kettle the light squared Bishop on B7
and still ultimately end up trading off
the dark Squad Bishop in order to
increase Black's control of the E4
Square
yep and you you wonder why sometimes
people spend time in the opening it's
like how many moves could I play here as
black and they would be basically decent
or good moves I could think of probably
like more than six or seven that are all
fine for black oh yeah fine E6 D5 B6
Knight C6 rookie you know like the list
goes on and on
um so really I think Navara is as you're
seeing trying to select which line he
wants to play and of course you have to
make that decision early Daniel you
can't just make one move and then decide
later it's like no the way you commit
your pawns and pieces now affects your
setup for the whole game it totally does
and there's that B6 move by David
Navarre I'm expecting Hikaru to develop
his light squared Bishop to D3 uh A3 is
also a trigger kind of a lever that
white can pull whenever he wants to pull
it but there's generally no rush uh to
play a3n with a Pawn on C5 I have seen
uh players drop the bishop back to A5
because B E4 does not trap the bishop
that square is controlled by Black's
Pawn so so David will have the option of
keeping his light Square uh keeping his
dark Square Bishop alive
yeah it's a it's a nice okay here we go
flexible option Bishop A5 but of course
as we talk about it why would it happen
Bishop takes C3 and we see the entire
point of Bishop D2 come to fruition Now
The Bishop's on C3 and uh you have to
wonder like you know how quickly does
David Navarre want to deal with this
bishop sometimes you go for a slower
setup D6 Knight bd7 or Knight C6 or you
can try to force things right away with
the move Knight E4 so you take on C3
give up the bishop pair but then you're
making a claim that well actually I'm
gonna get it right back well if you can
take on C3 play D6 Knight D7 and Knight
F6 you've equalized completely with that
beyond a shadow of doubt the problem is
that takes a while and white could
actually cause some problems on Black's
King side a move like Queen C2 is not
out of the question and and one
variation the black already has to
calculate not saying that this is what a
car is going to go for is Queen C2
Knight takes C3 Bishop takes H7 and then
B take C3 you might say well I trap the
bishop but you have to evaluate the
bishop sack on G6 this doesn't happen to
be good for white but you know you you
can't just wave your hands around uh and
and say I'm gonna make these five moves
and I'm gonna equalize it is a pretty
concrete position and the Evo bar seems
to believe that uh Hikaru has a pretty
sizable advantage and this is exactly
how you get it Queen D6
and I I was going to say like the way
that white has played this opening it
definitely feels like Hikaru prepped
that you know like this is a well-known
line the way that Navara played it is
not you know weird at all so I feel like
he totally expected this so it's
interesting that he's probably well
within his preparation and there's a
we'll get to the nepo game which just
started but there's a big problem here
if black tries to defend the C5 Pawn
then White's Queen actually drops back
to E5 forking the Bishop from the G7
Pawn David Navara might already be in
trouble and guess what I'm on Hikaru
found a way to punish him for delaying
his Queen side development Queen D6 is a
really scary move and I think black is
just either losing a pawn or he has to
open the G file which is kind of out of
the question so David Navarro already
facing opening problems we will leave
him to them let's catch the start of the
yannapanushi Peter spitler game I'm very
excited to see what openings they are
going to bring to the table
yeah this this match uh getting underway
very very uh Curious myself and we we
actually have
um so is it uh yeah nepo has the white
pieces to start off here E4 very
standard for uh for these top guys
lately and you can see the uh sort of
slow pace to the uh the game so far by
Peter and this is one thing that I
expected Daniel I'll be paying attention
to in this match nepo is so dang fast
like he he just doesn't slow down even
when he should even when it's like very
complicated hey maybe take a minute or
two to evaluate nope he's lightning
lightning quick and Peter is a little
more measured tempered he takes his time
and Peter is one of the foremost
specialists in the Marshall gamma nobody
plays into the Marshall anymore what I'm
talking about is the move C3 which used
to be the main move at one moment uh but
the Marshall according to sort of the
modern consensus just basically
equalizes there's uh not much to discuss
and so players have been going with
these anti-martial approaches A4 they've
been throwing in D3 uh and this position
has been hotly disputed uh in top level
chess now for for well over a decade
yeah this is um I mean it's so
interesting you see how
um Theory develops in chess because it's
like how could the evaluation of
something change so drastically that the
Marshall used to be like maybe what is
this move C3 white goes for D4 all of a
sudden black comes in with the Marshall
and suddenly we've got to a point where
nobody even wants to deal with it so
they're playing all these anti-martial
moves A4 is one of them h3s another one
and uh yeah as as we see in the game
here that's exactly what's happened I
still can't get over the fact that nepo
is sitting there remember there's only
plus two increment on these games and
look at nepo's cloth he's already up
three like two minutes right we're still
like deep within Theory and this is what
really concerns me I'm on about Peter
svidler we saw the uh Wesley so Vasily
Von shook match right we saw Ivonne
chick holding his own on the board but
just getting into
epic trouble on the clock every game I'm
a little little bit worried that we
might see a similar narrative and
storyline in this match so let's keep an
eye on Peter Fiddler's clock he's got to
make these opening decisions crisply to
leave himself with enough time to deal
with nepo's you know devilish middle
game style because you know nepa's going
to be causing you problems on every move
absolutely absolutely
um the guy is playing a bullet game I
wanted to talk about that A5 move for a
second might look a little weird uh for
white to just I don't know commit so
much at the beginning of the game to
just pushing this a pawn for what you
know why don't we play D3 D4 but if you
go to the position he moves back before
white played A5 then I think it if you
if you just put like you know D3 Knight
A5 or something uh maybe D6 and then
Knight A5 on the on the board
um black wants to use that square for
maybe their night and the bishop on B3
can feel a little awkward and there's a
lot of cases like horror stories where
the bishop goes to A2 and exactly you're
showing it something like
your partner Pawn takes C5 black rings
that night back to C6 and the bishop on
A2 once dominating the light squares
dominating the board is now reduced used
to a total passivity a pile of just just
a dumpster fire here on A2 so you often
see white just desperate oh there's
anything to open up the diagonal for my
Bishop let me breathe I'll give I'll
give as many pawns as you want uh but
you're exactly right and so A5 fixes uh
stops 985 and also it fixes weaknesses
on the queen side it's a double-sided
coin yes A5 needs to be defended but so
does A6 you can see Fiddler there giving
away the A6 spawn but winning A5 in
return so my guess is that nepo is going
to strike at the center with D4 uh but
he's gonna wait for black snide to move
away from C6 okay so we have another
game we have the lebonaroni and Maxima
God game shall we take a gander at that
one yeah let's let's catch the opening
phase of that game as well see how
things started out here as uh I already
see a position that well looks like it
has a serious likelihood of of just
neutralizing completely that's my that's
my first impression as I get here Daniel
yeah I don't think we're going to spend
too long on this one Lavon played a
pretty creative opening he played a
Bishop's opening but at the end of the
day Maxim he played this E4 move
exploiting a pretty simple tactic d494
94 Bishop takes B3 everything is getting
captured and traded and after Rook takes
C4 we get a bishop versus knight
situation but in this case I'm on with
the center as wide open as it is I don't
think that either side's minor piece is
appreciably better I think this is dead
equal and you know I'm gonna assign this
an 80 likelihood of of an of a first
round draw which would be a great result
by the way uh for Maxine to hold them on
so confidently with the black pieces
uh absolutely
um if you want to pull up an analysis
board and just go back to the move E4
um because if Lavon is one or move 14
yeah move one of course let's break down
all the whole tree here
um yeah this move right here if you're
Lavon and you're thinking okay he can
clearly calculate this de line he sees
the full liquidation if he wants a
little bit more from this game you might
think about the move d4 kind of keep the
pawns together and I I think the idea
was like Knight A5 maybe to try to get
on these light squares here the C4
square and it's just an interesting
standoff between these two Bishops on B3
and E6 nobody wants to take the other
one so Black's maybe even gonna play
Bishop D5 you know just once again tempt
you to take but I think this is a
position that was just well calculated
by uh Matt Lacon he didn't want
um I think to allow any position where
the the two Bishops really breathe so he
neutralizes everything and he's is
liquidated the whole board with E4 and
hey he's playing with the black pieces
against the aronian you definitely take
uh all equality in game one
yeah and obviously the game is very far
from over Lamont is going to try uh to
orchestrate some some Shenanigans down
the defile he establishes his Rook on D5
but I think Maxime with no targets no
weaknesses in his position should be
able to hold the draw let's go back to
the Hikaru game I know a lot of fans a
lot of players eager uh to watch Hikaru
try to dismantle David Navarro and we
already have a very interesting position
in game one nimso Indian Hikaru
resolving the central tension to his
favor and he stands much much better
here oh my God David Devar ended up
taking on F3 Amman to preserve the pawn
on C5 but look at this pressure on G7
look at that Bishop sniping away at
Black's kingside
there is nobody worse than Hikaru to
have this position against
yeah it really couldn't be if if you
also look at the Knight coming into C6
like if white even takes the time to
play F4 that Knight just doesn't go
anywhere you know B4 D4 E5 all covered
White's just gonna go long castle and if
things weren't going well enough long
castling for white also threatens Rook
takes D7 when the Knight moves so we're
castling maybe the tempo then we're
going Rook G3 and then it's either Rook
other Rook to G1 pressure on G7 or Rook
to H3 and the H Pawn is is loose so I
just don't see black surviving here what
are the defensive resources yeah you
could you could see black losing this in
like two seconds E5 by David I mean yeah
I get that it closes down the bishop but
look at the gaping holes that it creates
in the center uh you pointed out the
move F4 and now this move could serve to
open the bishop back up in fact if if
Hikaru plays F4 now could we just take
it
well oh you take on f4 on E5 because I'm
looking for like the same kind of I'm
wondering like how let me show so the
point is after EF you play Queen D5
picking up the rook in the corner so
Amaya's proposing Bishop E5 and Hikaru
has played E4 but this was a fascinating
idea attacking G7 and threatening a fork
on D5 I guess black has Rook F7 though
no right no oh no oh
what a tactic beautiful this would have
been an amazing mate but there is a
defense in this position and it is G6
oh and after Queen D5 you say I'm
winning the rook in the corner right but
if you calculate one move to the end the
queen is trapped
yep well there you go that's how I would
uh lose the game with whites yeah no
that way you saw the whole line and just
testing my ability to spy uh defensive
resources and Hikaru has indeed played
the move F4 this game come on might not
last uh much longer this is a disaster
it will
um you also look at the time Daniel and
it's like okay great you're being
attacked this isn't even a Blitz game
Hikaru Nakamura has seven minutes to try
to like orchestrate the right attack
that is so much it's really an eternity
when no it's defensive positions now
when you're playing NC car you're at
this point you're not even looking at
his clock he's got time to calculate
anything he wants to calculate how is
the game likely to go well he takes F4
is not possible D6 by Navara to defend
the pawn on E5 it's now plus five
I mean I think the car is just gonna
Castle yeah something as simple as
castling
and after Knight D7 just to show you how
winning the system on even if you go
Queen G4 Rook F7 and queen E6 forget the
G7 Pawn forget checkmate
positionally black is busted as well
yeah it's not a case where you've
sacrificed something for this black is
going to be the one down material yeah
and it's going to be the kind of game
where the engine's gonna say oh it's
plus five and the material could still
be equal but that's how bad the position
is
no every every move I look at for black
just loses the pawn on D6 or loses the
pawn on G7 and you get mated not to
mention uh let alone the ideas of f take
C5 and then pushing the other Pawn to F4
exactly uh to clear the diagonal no this
is over I mean this is basically
resignable for black
yeah I think I think you make a few
moves try to get your knight into the
game but once you realize that you're
lost even with your knight in the game
that's when I think the towel starts to
be uh consider throwing that one in
you know it's so rare in these lines uh
when the Knight lands on e4 if we rewind
just for a second how did all of this
happen to David Navara when he played
the move 94 he was not expecting Hikaru
to give away what is often the greatest
asset for white in the position but
Nakamura just sniffs these resources out
so quickly and he finds them a hundred
percent of the time after Queen D6 the
situation was already pretty dire for
black
and oh it's on the board
the line that I just showed that that's
a it's a really nice line because it
shows that you're not in any Rush you're
not you know frantically trying to play
F takes E5 upon F4 you're not trying to
play Rook G3 Rook G1 it's you're just
playing with the queen and showing how
one piece can just dominate a position
in Hikaru takes that d-pawn and his
Advantage only increase it
why not I mean F6 is going to be hanging
look at that pawn on C5 it's a total
Sitting Duck and once Hikaru wins this
Pawn he's gonna have a three on one on
the on the queen side I mean I've seen
crazier things happen uh Hikaru isn't
Flawless in his conversion yeah but I
don't think I have ever seen him you
know
screwing up a position like this with
six and a half minutes on his clock yeah
I just think that's not uh this isn't
the part of the game where Hikaru is
going to be making a bunch of uh
mistakes uh the conversion phase for him
especially after like he chose to go for
this it wasn't just how things worked
out
um which sometimes is the case it's just
the best line happens to trade your
Queens when you're attacking but he
chose to go for this which means he's
comfortable with it he you can already
see the variations and I mean this
Knight doesn't go to maybe 97 or 95 but
F6 is hanging right with the Rook on G1
white can just seriously think about
taking on F6 right absolutely could
think about taking on F6 maybe Knight F4
is the way to muddy the waters I think
your car is going to miss the fork on E2
yeah
Fat Chance of that but Knight F4 rookie
one is is game over no this is uh
barring barring some sort of a miracle
or a blunder as resilient as David
Navarre is and he is an unbelievably
resilient Defender
I mean we're talking about Hikaru here
this one is all but in the bag in the
meantime we have a lot of
transformations in the Jana pondichi
Peter svidler game so let's pan out to
that one
and update you all on what's going on
there
wow no more Rook Simon we need
directions yeah exactly yeah really uh
interesting development very interesting
structure because
Bishop on G2 is definitely a great piece
um but when it comes to like which
structure do I prefer you know at its
core probably I prefer a Peter Fiddler
with the black pieces but it's the way
the white pieces are organized that is
just a little bit better than blacks the
bishop on G2 strikes the D5 Pawn the
Knight on A5 feels a little aimless and
the Knight on D4 is so well situated
White's Queen by the way hasn't joined
the action yet Queen D2 Queen A1 if that
Queen gets involved in any way all of a
sudden the Knight starts looking silly
gotta move that piece around and I could
definitely see the the pot once the pawn
on D5 Falls you're very concerned that's
black so you gotta hold on to that pawn
for dear life and if you try to play on
the dark squares whites light Square
pawns on the king side Dania that might
be the difference if Peter can somehow
arrange his Queen and maybe like Queen
E5 as you're highlighting Knight B7
Knight D6 just reroute the pieces
um that might be what he needs to go for
so very double-edged game right now and
I don't think the engine is preferring
one side or the other too much it's just
uh you know one of those positions where
he made the better player win yeah the
engine just says I abstain I I don't
want to break any sides here I'm going
to stay unbiased but it is equal you
know I think if I I really like the look
of Queen E5 I think Peter has to play it
quickly he's down to five and a half
minutes Napo of course is
as hours left on his clock he's got 11
minutes or so oh yeah uh which is
totally typical Nepal could consider the
move C3 as a way of anchoring in the
Knight on D4 but that creates another
permanent weakness uh so maybe he should
refrain from pushing any of his pawns
and instead Focus as you were suggesting
uh on activating his Queen putting it
let's say on D2 but uh your point is
well taken this is not just a dead draw
uh and I think the pressure is on Peter
given that he is the one down five
minutes but we E5 is on the board and Mr
svidler seems to be up to the task wait
Nepal already played Queen D2 he had
basically pre-moved it he pretty much
did and I think at this point where
where there's so few options on the
board nepo is one of the best players in
the whole world I think at like thinking
on his opponent's time because he
already barely spends his own time so I
actually think if you pull up some stat
like nepo might do most of the thinking
in his game not on his clock which is
like a funny thing to think about but
hey when sfiddler is the one using all
the time nepo's sitting there he's
calculating and that's exactly what the
you know the strong players do to put
you under time pressure when you're busy
spending five minutes thinking they're
evaluating what move are you probably
gonna play what's the best move what's
on your mind what's the Practical chance
and he's got to move ready for it that's
the worst feeling in chess Daniel you
spend so much time and you're like oh
yeah this is an absolute you know Wicked
move I know I got everything worked out
yeah yeah he sees every that's where I
still think he sees everything this
guy's a machine uh so many people have
said that of nepo uh I I'm considering
the interesting resource B3 by black
trying to exploit the fact that the
queen is anchored to the knight uh so
after B3 I actually think B3 is a really
strong move because if white plays C3
your maneuver Knight B7 Knight C5 Knight
D3 could end up being quite scary and of
course the fight takes on A5 black takes
on D4 and again here white is actually
in trouble because these pawns on the
queen side are incredibly weak so I
think after B3 if anybody has to be
careful it might be nepo but Peter
Fiddler is taking
eternities oceans of time on every move
here and in the blink of an eye he is
down to three minutes and Amman he's
going to start getting nervous if he
drops below a minute Peter isn't totally
what he used to be in terms of his time
scrambling ability and he has to keep a
little bit of a buffer zone even if his
position is good he has decided on the
Move C3
and I mean you're not leaving many
options so as I was about to say you're
going to see the reply very quickly here
from from nepo because he doesn't have
many things to consider Knight C4 is the
move often the difference Daniel between
two really really strong players
especially in a situation like this it
is the time right I just see two legends
playing in front of me and it's like
okay what's going to be the difference
between them well if you know one of the
guys can play to this position seven
minutes faster than the other that's a
difference and that has to be you know
seriously considered as a you know one
of nepo's biggest assets that he puts
his opponents his very strong opponents
under time pressure and then of course
everyone's gonna play moves that are a
little bit subpar for their standard
when when you're under time pressure he
just did the classic nepo like shaking
his head from side to side look okay
maybe uh
um and the sort of you know Michaela
moroney not impressed not impressed face
uh I I would imagine that he's not too
impressed with his own play here I think
Peter did a great job of solving all the
opening problems the big question in
this game will is six and a half minute
time Advantage make its presence felt as
we move on to the end game stage of this
game in the meantime in the meantime I
think lavon's game is still pretty
balanced but Hikaru is about to win
David nevara's night so perhaps we
should catch the end of that game
yeah
um let's move back to
or maybe not maybe it's not as simple as
I thought it was what's going on here H3
is definitely like that's Hikaru
sniffing out the possibility of winning
this Knight though you don't yeah yeah
you don't play H3 unless on your mind
I smell nice but what exactly is he
gonna do a knight takes H3 is it just
Rook F1
oh it is a tough one isn't it and then
the other room
yeah
and look at that pawn enough for
restricting the knight from yeah that's
pretty nice trading to G5
does black have no here black has
nothing to do but somehow the evil bar
seems to believe that perhaps black and
magically extricate the Knight
like maybe king f8 or something like I
feel like maybe we need a rook somehow
getting involved because the H Pawn is
gonna do nothing for you and now it's up
to plus four and the problem is that in
addition I'm on to rookie two Bishop B3
and Bishop takes E5 nobody canceled yeah
the idea of just winning all of Black's
Pawns
so yeah Rook V8 by David
yeah oh yeah it's the it's the lateral
defense right somehow getting Rook B3 to
save the Knight
yeah The Rook comes swooping in yeah
I think even Bishop B3 here is
completely winning Bishop E3 you might
say oh but this lets the Knight Escape
back to E4 well yeah it does but after
rookie six you lose the C5 pawn and like
I had said earlier the three on one is
going to be totally decisive so I think
you guys got his choice of winning lines
here
I I there's something about like my my
brain really just doesn't feel
comfortable allowing 94 Knight G3 and
like Knight takes F5 that's the one Pawn
that I that I can't defend so I would be
a little more attached to somehow
trapping this Knight and it seems like
at least with this move he's leaning
towards that but wow look at this Moon
Knight to H1 slippery piece and Amanda
you called it Bishop E1 the idea is Rook
B3 to pave the way for the knights
Escape back to G3 and Hikaru is only up
a quote unquote only up a pawn right now
so if he doesn't win the Knight he's
kind of put all of his eggs in one
basket right
um the one thing that is a little bit
forcing is that with Bishop E1 so let's
say you start with Rook D3 first Rook D3
then H4 is forced because you have to
give the Knight an anchor square and
Bishop E1 and it seems like eventually
the Knight is gonna get to G3 right and
you're gonna take and you are gonna be
up two pawns there without black having
any inroads into the position I gotta
say this does look fairly convincing as
well so I think this is a nice option if
you're getting nervous as Hikaru like Oh
I thought I was trapping that night uh
you know when you're starting to second
guess it's nice to know that this is
available
yeah he's down in two minutes so what I
wouldn't do is take you know another
minute and a half to try to figure out
how to trap the Knight and Hikaru is an
incredibly practical decision making
decision maker speaking of which this is
exactly what he chooses Rook D3 and
Bishop E1 so depressing David Navarro
raises his hands up I got my night out
well congratulations you have a rook end
game where you're down two pawns and
you're down to a minute on the clock
yeah some prize
some prize so Knight H1 you know the
intentional Knight H1 we know that
Knights are literally at their absolute
worst in the corner because they only
have two squares to move to you talk
about the scope of knights why you don't
place it on the side of the board and
certainly why you don't place it in the
corner he has to play Knight G3 and yeah
I just uh I think this should be
reasonably routine for Hikaru definitely
uh I think Navara I think he's probably
got his best position in a really long
time but that doesn't say much yeah no
David hats off by by all means to David
for the resistance that he's put up here
the issue is that he was just too lost
to begin with this one's not totally
over though I mean you could see a
scenario where black maybe gets The Rook
into H4 if David could get to hikaru's
pawns on the king side then the
situation starts to complicate that's
right but he's not going to be able to
do that because the Rook on D7 for
example has to keep the E7 Square uh
under lock and key otherwise what's
Rook is going to infiltrate the seventh
Rank and that's a death sentence
and I was actually thinking that Hikaru
would have played like Rook e to G2
perhaps on the previous move to try to
lock down a rook on that g-pawn because
now with Rook h8 if you need to defend
G7 as black you can move the Rook up one
square to H7
um I think if my intuition is correct
they usually teach you to try to trade a
pair of Rooks here as white dealing with
two Rooks is is a little bit annoying
there's a lot of threats that can be
made and as white the Rooks are a little
Superfluous you're winning without the
Rooks on the board so any reduction of
of pieces is simply gonna take away
counter play for black and just make it
easier for your pawns to push up the
board
that's totally true
and Rook D2 to that end should be
seriously considered the downside of
playing Rook D2 is that after the trade
black can go and pick up the F5 Pawn but
perhaps that is a worthy price to pay to
be able to play before there's a rook
trade Hikaru gives up the H3 Pawn but
look how smartly he's done that and now
the king is going to invade D5 and the
game is basically over
yeah that's all called you got it that
was uh really really nicely done
um so I think as Navara here you're
you're looking at maybe Rook H2 and Rook
D2 to try to cut that King off but
Hikaru I think he just he's gonna bring
the Rook to the D file and make a bridge
so to speak so oh and the king is great
execution
yeah this is over on the spot because
the king is cut off you'll never make it
past the e-file without trading Rooks
and we know the pawn end game is lost so
I think just BC and CC 6 is probably
winning
well there's the calculation it's
written on the ceiling so he's just
gonna verify with it he takes C5
right where the smoke detector is
and yeah just doesn't make it around in
time C7 King D5 and the worst part about
this is that if there was no Pawn on C4
Daniel and you're highlighting it maybe
you can dream of those two pawns making
a difference on the king side but as it
stands it's gonna be a little bit closer
than people realize like Rook F3 G5 then
Black's gonna bring the king up and then
the pawns start to move really fast but
there's no way that black makes it in
time I think actually Rook B3 might be
the most precise move but then let's see
eight the car with 30 seconds he's got
to be a little bit careful basically the
point here is that you want to buy
yourself as many Tempe as possible so
that you can promote the other C Pawn
but that takes some time as well Rook B3
is on the board Rook C8 forced otherwise
Rook B8 I think uh I think strangely the
that I would have gone for Rook F3 just
because the Rook does really well in
front of the pawns you can never Advance
the pawns without the king at least
yep
King D6 oh G4 he wants King E5 I think
that's right
F6 needed to be Tried by Navara but then
when you're wasting a king move as black
white just go C5 and you know it's like
three moves till white gets a queen
yeah Lavon by the way is going to draw
his game that was a completely colorless
game all the way but we need to flip to
the Yon Nepal Nishi Peter Fiddler game
because that continues to become more
and more exciting
one game already in the book see Kara
Nakamura scoring
a victory in the first match game
against Navara here is the nepos Fiddler
position I think Peter has acquitted
himself tremendously despite his time
pressure
he has and we see the time I mean he's
come much closer to even here three
minutes a minute and a half yeah and
after Queen Dick's F7 both sides appear
to have like perpetuals almost in the
back yeah black as Queen a wanted if
Bishop F1 there's Knight D2 and then
time for white to give the perpetual
yeah nepo has that he's got that
Michaela Maroney face again he's not too
impressed with his round one
does round one draw yeah me
okay this is a decent result but not not
amazing
all of the games are now in the books
because the Iranian game has finished at
exactly the same time that one was
really a draw uh you know we kind of
could predict the results after 50 moves
or so yeah
since the start that was addressed since
the start let's review the scoreboard
three matches are in play three first
round games are concluded only one of
them is decisive Hikaru Nakamura wins is
around one game against David Navarre he
has a 1-0 lead and David will have his
work cut out for him as will the other
two underdogs who have to continue
playing in confident style all right we
are gonna go on a short break ladies and
gentlemen when we come back we will be
contesting game two of today's afternoon
round of 32 matches here at the cgc
don't go anywhere we'll be back with
more action in just a couple of moments
foreign
[Music]
akamura's iconic orange wall in the
memorabilia behind him this is a
backdrop that we are all so familiar
with the car Nakamura wins his first
game here in the round of 32 against
David Navara
I'm on a tour de force performance let's
let's be real about that David Navarra
basically had no chances in game one
he didn't
um he walked in to definitely opening
prep and I actually find it a little
ironic what I was saying I guess what I
meant was you're really not supposed to
find Bishop D2 as dangerous you can lose
the game in 10 moves prep but it was
exactly that
um the position was over not five moves
after Bishop D2 was played so pretty uh
pretty scary stuff that's hikaru's game
one prep what does he have in store with
the black pieces we now wonder
yeah and I guess what does David Navarre
have in store for the white pieces
because he has some coming back to do
the other two matches between nepo and
Peter svidler aronian matlikov ended in
relatively Placid draws the spiedler
Napo game was definitely I definitely
had a lot more meat on the bone let's
put it that way uh I'm on but Peter
Fiddler total kudos to him he held his
own for that entire game he did he did
great
he did fantastic by him he'll be happy
with that uh result and an aronian
Matlock nothing much to say about that
one not every single game is is gonna
have uh you know complete diatomism and
chances for both sides that was just a
well played game by both and Daniel when
chess has played at the highest level
well oftentimes it just looks like that
it does indeed and here we see a look at
the Players Navara he seems calm he
seems up to the challenge of coming back
with the white pieces the opening phase
uh Amman is going to be critical
hikaranakamura's Berlin the way he plays
against the Italian is basically
unbreakable if he has wanted to draw he
has made it essentially on demand let's
see what David Navarra has in store for
us in this Italian
yeah and I kind of Wonder is uh is
Navarre going to be thinking which I
think this is always after a tough game
one you always have this moment with
yourself do you take a bunch of risks as
this is your first game with the white
pieces yourself are you comfortable with
that draw and I think David Navara
especially against someone like Hikaru
needs to push here and the reason that I
think that is also because of the nature
of game number one that was only game
number one hikara with the white pieces
here he's clearly showing that he's well
prepped he's got a bit of a different
style some some different openings
prepared
um specifically against Navara and he
carves next game with white might be
just as lethal and tough to deal with so
you know if you're looking at a tough
game coming up next I think you have to
make a statement in this one if you're
David you absolutely dry do I'm not
going to say that drawing this loses you
the match but being down you know a
point going into the final two games one
of which you're gonna have with the
black pieces like you said given how
game one went yeah he absolutely needs
to try to step on the gas pedal here
and that's what he's doing this is a
good opening choice right the Italian is
a pretty open-ended opening there are no
Force draws there are no equivalents of
the Berlin and David Navarra he's got to
play what he's comfortable with and I
think that's exactly the approach that
he's trying to take now I'm on the
Italian isn't an opening that you play
for an early opening Advantage you're
not going for the quick knockout you're
going for a long-term positional
struggle
yeah and it's important to remember that
a lot of chess openings the very best
ones
um we even saw a good example um if you
remember last game uh or last round the
game between aronian and matlikov right
that's an example of a game that Navara
does not want at all in this round
something you know that just liquidates
quickly where it's like easy easy ways
to trade a lot of pieces and especially
open up the center so the Rooks just get
vacuumed off the board so that game is a
good example of what you don't want and
this game is the exact contrast right
now all of a sudden the center's not
opened up yet the pieces are still
finding their homes no immediate trades
moves you know A6 and A4 have been
played to actually tuck those Bishops
back in on A7 on A2 that's specifically
to avoid trades you know H3 to avoid the
pin so just the nature the way these
moves are coming out there's no Pawn
tension at the moment no pawns are
attacking one another and peace trades
are just hard to come by so I agree I
think this is what Navara wants not
saying this is an opening uh you know
that has a big advantage and not saying
that Hikaru has made a mistake to be
here but if you want to spice things up
and give yourself a long game with some
chances no maybe you're happy uh with
the Vara here
oh I like I like the opening Choice the
issue is that Hikaru is kind of an E5
specialist and that's how he has
fashioned himself in the last couple of
years he proved that once again in the
candidates tournamental though he lost a
game to team over a job of but by and
large yukara has been getting excellent
positions on the black side of of the
Berlin Roux Lopez and on the black side
of the Italian so here we see the pawns
on A4 and B4 as is the modern fashion
right this isn't how people used to play
the Italian uh I don't think white
almost ever put the pawn on B4 but in
the last couple of years white has
practiced the sort of Queen side
expansion the ideal scenario is Knight
C4 followed by B5 and Amman you could
see a scenario where this gets really
dangerous for black really quickly for
example let's say after Knight C4 black
Dilly dallies let's make a random move
after B5 ab5 ab5 no problem the bishop
is different but it's okay after B6 you
can already resign so yeah we're not
talking about some hypothetical play
here 20 moves Down the Line This is a
clear and present danger and so you
often see black players doing here is
trying to quickly go for King side
counter play either with a rook lift uh
or with you know Knight H5 Knight F4
some sort of maneuver to muddy the
waters on the king side
yeah and um the the funny thing about
your line there which I really enjoyed
was your random king h8 move it honestly
was not even that bad like you were
doing th8 let me make this awful move to
show variation
was like actually that's pretty good
okay and Rigby won by Mr Navarro B5 is
being prepared uh he is not hiding his
intentions on the queen side and I am
very curious to see how Hikaru Nakamura
sort of arranges his pieces on the king
side here he goes for the typical Knight
C6 to E7 to G6 maneuver which largely
kind of takes the sting out of the move
B5 that move no longer comes with tempo
and I think uh I mean it's not a a
really serious idea but with the Rook on
A1 if you play B5 you do have to watch
out for Bishop takes F2
um and if if that happens to you you're
definitely
you definitely caught a little bit off
guard so Rook B1 just getting off the
the a file B5 wants to happen Knight C4
but you mentioned it really typical idea
here I think everyone who plays E4
watches these games
um you know definitely something to
remind yourself of white could do the
same plan Knight F1 Knight G3 Black's
going for it with Knight C6 to E7 97 to
G6
yeah copying each other you often see at
nights on F3 and G3 Knights on F6 and G6
do we have here a pretty standard
Italian position but Hikaru already up
three minutes on the clock we will keep
a very close eye on this middle game but
right now let's keep an eye on the
siddler nepo game it has just begun let
us make a quick tour of our remaining
two matches and Peter svidler with the
white pieces one E4 and a Bishop's
opening which is what Levon aronian
played against Malikov in their game one
yeah and this Bishop's opening as we
call it is basically just the you know I
I like to refer to it as the anti-petron
um you know when you when you play A4 E5
uh Knight F3 Knight F6 black is playing
one of the most you know equalizing and
dare I say boring openings in in chess
very symmetrical
um and Bishop to uh C4 The Bishop's
opening this is designed uh against a
player that you already know plays the
Petro off this way so you're you're
saying look I know if I play Knight F3
then you're probably gonna play Mad F6
and so Bishop C4 avoids that and gives
you other options to continue playing
the game but that in mind before Bishop
but but they told me to develop my
nights before Bishops yeah they're
exactly let's not pretend that there is
no downside to this opening right there
is no free lunch in chess when you avoid
one opening uh you open another entirely
different can of worms and the can of
worms that you have open here well
there's multiple the E4 Pawn is sort of
hanging there was a threat of trapping
the bishop
and just visually nepo's position looks
great I mean he's got the center uh
provided that he can keep the E5 Pawn
nicely defended him on it already
appears to me that he solved all of his
opening problems
yeah yeah absolutely and I think when
you play moves like uh Castle here as
black first of all it shows that you're
well prepped but there's just so many
hanging Pawns in this position that
nobody seems to care about E4 hanging
yeah E5 hanging it's like okay who's
gonna blink first type of thing because
clearly some of these pawns can be taken
and at least should be taken and Knight
takes E5 they aren't happy to see it
let's let's see the uh let's see the
proof
yeah Mr nepo uh your Pawn is hanging why
don't you show me what you got
and nepo says sure I'm going to show you
what you got and what he's got is Queen
C7 attacking the Knight and if the
Knight moves back to F3 then nepo
recaptures 94 let's bring up an analysis
board uh delve a little bit into these
complications so after d takes E4 D
takes C4 Knight takes C4
I don't think white isn't too white is
in any trouble Amon but this could get a
little bit unpleasant rookie eight why
it's not castled yet and it's obvious
that nepo is not worse here so Peter
svidler F2 F4 a an ambitious move wow
and uh he tries to keep the Knight
established on E5 nepo still recaptures
the pawn 94. the one problem for nepo
here might be his lack of development
can Peter spitler punish Yan for
delaying the development of his entire
Queen side what do you think
and uh there's there's something that
seems a little bit interesting here
um if you pull up an analysis board
Dania let's say that White Castles
because we want to say all right we
don't care about this Pawn I'm just
looking at the move A4 followed by the
move Queen B6 check and before you know
it it's like things could be going
really wrong here on the B2 Square now
still lots of counter play the other way
but this is something that you just
don't account for when maybe you Castle
you just throw that move out don't even
see that hey there's like a two three
move tactic incoming
and I think that is precisely why Peter
svidler decided to start with Knight C3
that prevents A4 uh and obviously Queen
B6 is not as effective and white is
uncastled
Peter in this position might actually be
thinking about just castling and
ignoring the pawn on D3 prioritizing his
development but I don't really think
that's his style my guess is that he's
going to recapture on D3 but the issue
Amman is after Queen takes D3 Knight bd7
I mentioned that there's no free lunch
well there's no free lunch that pawn and
F4 becomes a serious weakness in a lot
of these positions right if you move the
knight from E5 it's hanging if you don't
move the knight from E5 well black is
just threatening to take twice so it's a
very tense position and I can see either
side getting into some trouble here if
they're not careful
yeah and you know this this is a really
interesting game we've got from the
Bishops opening compare that to the
other Bishops opening game we saw so
just shows you um the the variation
selection that players make really
determines an opening uh it's not like
one specific opening is just boring in
every line uh I was gonna say might it
be interesting to see long Castle I know
short Castle is kind of the the move as
well but long Castle you know the Rooks
start to uh get to the middle and some
fun as Yasser would would say about long
Castle you would say
it's legal
yeah euphemism for uh
yeah I'm not so sure about that but and
there are any dudes on the board look at
you I'm on it is on the board Peter
svidler putting on his Mickey little
tall hat yeah Peter svidler I think met
Michael it's all when he was a kid he
was recently telling his story about
that but didn't quite have the you know
the the courage to speak to him
but here Fiddler's intentions are clear
and they are very bloody he wants to
Checkmate Yanda Panda Street on the king
side perhaps with a Jeep on March up to
G5 so my guess is he's gonna take back
with a knight and then send his Jeep on
down the board full send Black's gonna
go B5 and we're gonna get a good old
school opposite side castling barn
burner so get yourself ready folks for a
violent game
yeah okay we should check the Lavon game
by the way because crazy stuff is
happening there as well yep uh yeah
let's head over to that game and
obviously there will be a lot to come
back to in this one
but here Maxima lockup has sacrificed an
exchange the opening was a Catalan this
is a particular variation of the Catalan
if we rewind where the Queens are traded
very early this is a very very famous
line and in this position black plays C3
giving back the pawn in order to ruin
White's Queen Side Pawn structure it
comes at a cost though the cost that it
comes at is the B file and the fact that
White's light squared Bishop is a whole
lot better than its counterparts so I'm
on we had some maneuvering Maxime got
his Knight to D3 Lavon put some pressure
on E2
and then he won the exchange but Maxine
grabs V7 and now he grabs E5 and F7 is
also hanging has Lavon underestimated
White's compensation and maybe you can't
even talk about compensation because
white is technically up material
yeah it's one of those weird things like
did you win material I don't even know
if that's fair to say
um because this is one of the the spots
where you win something and it's as you
calculated but then it happens and
you're like
um okay wait a minute why why am I the
one that's happy about this you know I
spent the time calculating this must be
my variation how come you got a good
position
you know those moments when you
underestimate something and you get to
the position you say wait this was
supposed to be good and then you realize
that none of the ideas you had in mind
actually work I think that Lavon
seriously underestimated maybe the fact
that white has two pawns for the
exchange maybe the activity of White's
minor pieces I think the key for Maxime
here is to unfurl his remaining minor
pieces maybe go Knight B3 I guess first
he has to decide if he wants to keep the
additional pair of Rooks on the board if
you don't though if you play Rook takes
A7 I don't know the evil bar seems to
like it I'd be really scared to make
that move I mean after Bishop before
there's already a maid threat yeah I'm
very scared you know what's weird about
this position is that with the King on
E1
my brain is like wait a minute how did
whites Rook from H1 just finish
like yeah is that possible yeah it just
fell off the the board a little bit it
just uh you know slipped off H1 and no
one bothered to put it back it's like
wait a minute what wait how did it oh
because white actually this is rare
White Castle kingside and then brought
his King manually back to its initial
position no I didn't remember that I was
starting to investigate how it happened
yeah so strangely we actually have the
king whose Castle The Rook was lost and
then yep marching right back into the
center and a lot of pieces are actually
pretty close to their starting squares I
totally agree with you Rook takes A7 oh
I just there's I can't play that move it
looks so risky but
um hey when you start picking up all the
Pawns in the position the onus starts to
be on aronian it's like hang on man at
some point you gotta prove something
because now that's three pawns plus plus
that monster Bishop from G2 on the A8
square that eight Pawn gonna become a
queen in due course yeah that red carpet
is gonna be unrolled pretty quickly so a
big decision here for maxim I mean yeah
I could totally see a case being made
for for a trade of Brooks and the Knight
P3 but the common wisdom is that when
you're down in exchange you want to keep
an additional pair of Brooks on the
board because minor pieces aren't always
capable of you know handling themselves
particularly well when there's a rook
jumping from one side of the board to
another so you could have all the Pawns
in the world but you're often still
craving a rook so we'll leave Maxine to
make this important decision we'll check
back into this fascinating end game
pretty soon uh shall we fly on over to
Nakamura International Airport take a
look at that Italian game what do you
think
absolutely yeah the uh we haven't been
there in a little bit and I want to see
uh what if any progress Navara has made
towards you know a semblance of an
advantage because I've been saying I
think this is a critical game for him
um for example you hand a draw to Hikaru
first of all
where is Hikaru I was gonna say like is
he is he with us he seems really
distraught here and I was gonna say the
musician's good has he blundered a queen
yeah is he down is he down a piece and
no and no
he's dead I just wanted to make sure
that I was counting the material right
there because I was about to say hey
Carl's done a great job and then I
looked at Hikaru and I was like no way
okay maybe not maybe he hasn't what's
wrong here it's funny that chess
player's face is like almost never
correspond to the position that's on the
board it's like a very risky thing
whoa
oh that was such a cool move by David
look at that let's pull up an analysis
report because it looks like he
plundered a knight but yeah you and I
were like in shock for a moment because
there's actually two ways to trap the
queen can you believe that he's worth
before and Knight D2 and both of these
moves trapped the queen on C4 so Hikaru
saw that and he had actually pre-moved
Knight take C4
it's important by the way uh you know
really important just to establish that
that dominance that if you play the move
D takes E4 as white and as black if you
don't have Knight takes E4 pre-moved you
lose a lot of credibility as a grand
master because then it's like oh ha ha
you didn't see that this was a trap it's
like even if even if you can then just
play The Right Move Knight takes Pawn
the fact that you pre-move it lets your
opponent know yeah yeah cool move buddy
but I saw it as well this had no chance
of working yeah right it was it was not
even close mind freins Queen takes C4
now is on the board of course the
landscape
has changed quite a bit that Queen still
has D5 and it also is attacking the C3
pawn and David Navarro's Bishop on A7 is
hanging so I would imagine
that the natural move is to bring the
bishop back to D4 but then you have to
reckon with moves like Rook A2 you know
these open Center positions Hikaru is so
so dangerous and because there's a high
risk of blundering something or missing
a tactical detail uh but not if you're
Hikaru Nakamura again I think if you uh
take the Queens off the board I might
like that Bishop a little bit more but
with the bishop uh and the Queen's on
the board something about the position
just looks so much easier for hikarana
to play so
I wouldn't even be surprised to see
maybe Naka start pushing it really
depends what David does but you got this
loose Bishop on A7 you highlighted it if
that Bishop Retreats Rook A2 and these
are the tricky moves that need to be
played Knight to D4 everything is
hanging in this position what is
happening the engine is like guys it's a
draw chill out stop making a mountain of
a molehill it's just equal
um and we are going to have some sort of
liquidation here but I'm trying to
figure out
first of all how white restores the
material equality let okay I was going
to say let's bring up an analysis board
but but they're making moves so quickly
uh I think this is just gonna fizzle out
into a draw this is exactly the way that
David Navara should play Knight takes C7
I think basically ends the game Rook
takes a seven Rook takes B1 and it's
time to sign the Peace Accords
that that was incredible how quickly and
that's just a testament to how well
these two can calculate because they
were both on the same page but they were
on a page that nobody else was on yeah
they are on page 600 and we're we're
still you know reading the preface to
the book
um is this just a Dedra does anybody
have any minuscule chances I don't think
so I don't think either side is in any
danger of losing their respective beep
on
maybe I don't know white has chances if
anything just feel like you can try to
bring the Rook around like Rook D1 d d a
B8 exactly and like you can sort of
dream but the thing is there's the
counter play the other way is always so
Swift Rook A1 check Rook A2
and you just can't defend everything no
this Knight is perfectly placed you can
never play G3 because you drop H3 if you
play H4 then you create other weaknesses
no this is
uh this is a 99
99 confident that this is going to end
in peace and like you said a fantastic
result for Nakamura holding effortlessly
with black or so it seemed he really was
in under no pressure throughout the
entire game I mean I was comfy yeah that
was comfortable uh he drew from a
position of strength and he's gonna have
the white pieces and a chance to put it
all away in the next game
yep I don't think we will see this one
last too long so we can leave it at this
and say this is a very very likely draw
we need to switch to the Peter Fiddler
game because it is getting crazy ladies
and Gentlemen let's switch to our
opposite side castling barn burner in
swindler neponishi both minor pieces are
hanging look at what is happening Knight
back to E5 was the last move by civil
there was a trade and nepo is he gonna
move the Knight does somebody like nepo
do that no C4 counter-attacking the
bishop what is happening here holy
smokes okay well we we promised this
would be an exciting one to come back to
and it certainly is the first move that
you you should all be calculating I
think is Pawn takes Knight it's the most
forcing it's the one that deserves the
evaluation
um and wow I was about to say
meme D6 holy smokes so he really didn't
like some of the complications there did
uh did Peter
yeah let's let's bring up an analysis
board I wanted to show first of all some
people might be attracted to Queen G5
Unstoppable mate uh Unstoppable made the
other way the problem is that CB opens
up the C file so I I can't blame Peter
for disliking this position the pressure
on C2 is really really annoying so
instead he chooses Queen D6 and I guess
the idea I'm on is that after Queen
takes D6 you have to take with the Rook
you have to keep contact with the Knight
obviously
what worried me initially is the move
Knight to E8 is spidler gonna take a
page out of Mexi matlikov's book and
sacrifice an exchange in the end game I
think he is yeah that's awesome you know
he also has the idea of Rook d8
um and then Knight B6 I don't know if
that works but uh looks like something
Knight B6
Definitely Maybe you could start with
Knight B6 instead of Rook d8 I'm not too
sure but yeah this idea of like trying
to win that piece back so it looks like
he's got options which is very nice he's
spoiled for Choice here but I think
after Bishop takes C4 I wouldn't want to
have like this position in a rapid game
with black this seems so much easier and
more fun to play with white unless you
lose the D6 spawn but that doesn't seem
to be uh even a remote possibility at
this point so nepo has an important
decision to make after Queen D6 Queen
takes D6 is not forced
but if you don't take on D6 what do you
do where do you put your queen
because ef6 and queen takes have fate
becomes the big threat
yeah I guess you know you could do Rook
a seven
um to defend the queen that's that's one
idea but I'm I'm looking at this
position I'm seeing once again tail of
the tape
Janda palmnushy with a huge time match
and the thing is while it evens up
towards the end of the game
what Yan does is he he's doesn't take a
lot of time with decisions that are not
very critical and he leaves himself with
that mountain of time on his clock to
evaluate the stressful positions like
this like the ones that need attention
and in this position you see svidler
he's only got three minutes in change
he's probably even making the move Queen
D6 because of the time pressure
and he needs Clarity in the position he
needs it very quickly because you're not
going to survive 10 more moves of
Anarchy and Chaos with less than four
minutes on your clock but you're
absolutely right nepo's time management
gives him the luxury of you want to take
five minutes on a move absolutely by all
means he can do that and still have the
same amount of time that Spiller has
yeah which basically means he's up five
minutes that was a very long-winded way
of saying that but you get the point
Rook takes D6 is on the board the Queens
are off the board
and now the big question do you go 98 or
do you play the simpler C takes B3 e
takes F6 When the Smoke finally clears
and it's hard to say who's got the
slight upper hand probably it's hard to
say
um
I think it's black
I I think that
um I think that the Knight on A4 really
wants to play Knight B6 and and trade
for something because if you get a
position where
um black captures the bishop and loses
an end in F6
I think that position is is really
uncomfortable for nepo with Queens
without Queens the pawn can be captured
I know it looks bad to open up your king
but when it comes to the end game you're
not as scared about that and black will
use the C file
Bishop somewhere like F5 Rook C8 totally
White's King is a little bit
uncomfortable
and that by the way is another benefit
of the Moon Knight B6 the fact that it
covers C8 but your earlier idea of Rook
A7 Rook C7 could circumvent that
potentially
gosh there's still so much going on
there's three separate pairs of Pawns
that are staring at each other okay B
take C2 is straightforward
and
okay now the ball is firmly back in
Fiddler scores he might want to grab on
G7 just to rid himself of this headache
instead he goes Knight B6
jeez
the Sparks are still flying even though
we have very few pieces left on the
board
yeah I think that was the right call by
swiddler
um just all things considered do you
keep this Knight because I'm not sure
taking is the way to go no cause that
well then black takes in defense C2
exactly and actually winning that pack
is gonna be a nightmare because B3 is
coming in yeah oh God don't even don't
even start with that but actually if you
look at the eval bar we've somehow come
back to parody here and maybe Fiddler
keeps the Knight with Knight D5 the
clock evening up I think dare I say
could this be the same as game number
one headed towards a draw after a huge
middle game scramble which Fiddler would
not mind at all the lower rated player
always wants things to boil down to one
critical game that raises the
probability and the possibility of
something crazy happening okay so it
looks like the smoke has more or less
cleared we are more or less expecting a
draw here uh Knight D7 maybe but Spiller
still has to be very very careful he is
down a lot of time on the clock okay the
Navara Nakamura game has not ended yet
and David Navara is down to 30 seconds
the levonne aronian game is heating up
as well which one should we go to next
well let's just have a look at where
hikaru's game stands because sure I
think we'll be able to tell with that
time pressure you know is this a real
push for either player yes or are we
basically wrapping this up this is a
real push for either player and it's a
real push for black
and the either player is the either one
named tikaru the one the one who's got
the black pieces here yeah um this is
not the situation you want to be in and
icaro definitely created this position
with just the skills that he has as as a
speed chess player because the the eval
everything about the position screamed
draw
um but if he car was able to win this
game Daniel that might just put this
match away not officially but
he blooded his Knight wait the Knight is
just hanging I think after Rook D.A I
think Rook da wins and he plays it it's
over rookie King D7 King D7 goodbye see
amazingly you need the square that your
Pawn occupies Ace or you needed A7
that's why Rook A7 was a blunder the
Knight had only one Escape square and it
was A7 both games I'm on David Navara
gets his Knight trapped essentially
and he's he was just betrayed there by
his own uh his own pieces both of them
the pawn and The Rook took both squares
this is going to be a vintage Chicago
Nakamura when you get an end game that
in which 90 of players would just agree
a draw and not only does he win it it's
not some 60 move Affair you know oh he
gets Navarre to time pressure and milks
it for 30 moves just wins the night on
move 40. the game is over he is up to
zero when he comes he's Unstoppable even
if he didn't win that night he was gonna
probably win that game so yeah it I feel
like it just accelerated things but with
20 seconds in a tough position Hikaru
looked like he was doing
you know already vintage girl stuff
where he was gonna pull away and now
with the 2-0 lead he just needs to draw
Dania and he certainly looks like he's
in great form in this match nobody has
made a 2-0 comeback in the cgc if
somebody does it for the first time and
it's against the car Nakamura then
you know the universe will practically
explode an impressive display in the
first two games and David Navarra is
doing his best but his best is not good
enough against the karanakamura's good
form I flipped to the molokov aronian
game where you might remember that white
sacrificed in exchange for two pawns
that's right and right now the position
does look pretty dynamically balanced we
have a repetition of moves will aronian
go along with it
I would be okay with the repetition
maybe for either side like one of the
fairest repetitions in chess right here
you're watching it because I definitely
think that if you don't go for it you
just might be immediately worse no
matter which side you are I think for my
scene Bishop takes before in King C3 I
could see a case being made for because
this bishop is really active you have
this idea of going e594 but I agree with
you Oman look at that apron black can
push that pawn to A3 creating an anchor
point for The Rook on B2 so you could
see this going astray really fast
totally totally understandable decision
yeah and another draw in game two this
match is tied 1-1 and that means we only
have one other game remaining that is
right swiddler against nepo here we go
very even match between aronian and
matlikov so looking forward to the rest
of those games there but in terms of
games that are still ongoing
we have one that you know the eval bar
is not given any credit here but as time
starts to tick lower and lower these
players especially spitler
I wonder is there going to be anything
between them White's position appears to
be
solid no this is just a draw nepo really
has one threat and that is Rook A2 so I
think similar could do well to evacuate
his King from under these con from the
confined space into the center where it
has uh plenty of Real Estate
spot the repetition okay well one of
them is okay King F6
King C2
some sort of like Roque 2 King D3 Rook
C8 Maybe
but that's not really a repetition I
think this is gonna go on actually I'm
on for maybe another 10 15 moves at
least King C2 Rook C8 King B2 Rook okay
uh I'll submit that into evidence wow
okay you're a lot better I see why you
proposed this game you knew you were
better at this game I I already knew
what I was gonna submit as my winning
answer and I'm just hoping that I could
get you to play along nepo's going for
it he's gonna go Rook A2 I know Jan he's
going Rook A2 he won't be able to resist
the temptation you're you're correct to
Shay my friend it's wonderful so now now
we've uh now we're 1-1 in our match
Rook C8
threatening Rook C3 which would win the
pawn on G2 so
no now once again White's Rooks are a
little funny because if you check with
either one of them the king moves and
and attacks of Rook so you can't just
check forever
yep
yeah the king the king would have moved
to E6 Rook D4 is a classy move by Mr
svidler I think after Rook C3 King E4
you're gonna get Mutual liquidation
White's gonna take B4 Black's gonna take
G2
and White's actually not worse there I
mean White's the one with the passer
in that position I think it's time for
nepo too
uh to to bring this one to an end
Rook e 2 King
I mean do you have to go King F4 you can
go King D5 also but then I would take on
G3 and take on YouTube then then you
lose a couple Pawns
so you should probably go King F4 and
maybe spot the draw attempt number two
right Rook F2 King E4 rookie two King F4
yep
okay
thinking but ziddler I have to say he's
still over a minute a month he has done
a fantastic job the end game was
relatively simple but he's not letting
himself drop to like two seconds on the
clock you know he's not doing the
grishek
no you don't want that
don't want that
not at all Rook F2 King G4 the thing is
after Rook F2 I don't think there's any
interest for Peter to play games before
he's gonna play King E4 for sure yeah
you don't want to press your luck there
no nepo's still going for a rook C2 okay
Rook takes B4
I think you take that pawn because even
though you can grab G2 as black white
will just move the H Pawn uh to safety
and there's also Rook B6 check
yeah I like how nepo's nepo's probably
thinking about throwing in Rook F2 and
he does
and Fiddler's like all right Jan let's
just you know let's take our break yeah
let's finish this show up Brook takes
you two and King H3 is a draw the funny
thing is even without White's B and H
spawns this would still be a theory yeah
that is that is a good point that people
should know this is a theoretical draw
with the h f bonds so white actually
doesn't need any of the pawns and he has
two
although making that draw is like when I
get a piece of Ikea furniture and it
comes with this card that shows you how
to assemble it there's no words on it
there's just 15 symbols and like you
know screws appear in various places I
know I'm never gonna do it
yeah you know not to mention a very very
happy caricature that's succeeding every
step
it'll be done oh it just takes 10
minutes drawing F and H is really
difficult but drawing this position is
not we end in peace two of the matches
are incredibly even two draws neither
side really having an advantage at any
point throughout no any of these four
games in neposvidler and Iranian Matlock
of them on this is gonna really come
down to the wire which is good for the
lower rated player it is I mean this is
going to be super exciting uh granted
hikaranakamura is very close to closing
out his match he's gonna have the white
pieces in game number three that's about
to happen but in the promise she's
Fiddler it's been so even we've seen
time advantages for Yan what's Fiddler
coming back defending well every single
game aronian Matlock I think has been
the closest match of all of them Dania
so really excited to see what happens
next me too and before we go on break we
want to remind you that the 2022-23
Collegiate chess league in partnership
with Nace Starly begins Saturday
September 24th that is today sign ups
close today for students so make sure to
sign up at go.chess.com CCL to represent
your school in the Premier chess league
for college students and on that note we
will be taking a short break you are
watching the chess.com Global
Championship we'll be back with game
three of these fascinating random 32
matches on the other side of this short
break
[Music]
foreign
oh yeah
[Music]
foreign
to anyone
all around the world are you kidding me
the chess.com Global Championship offers
the dream of playing against the best
whoa and hey have we mentioned there's
also a million dollars at stake the
total pot is a million dollars know that
it's not a typo the prizes are
unbelievably generous we began with
thousands of players now only dozens
remain you don't just do this to chakra
in a critical game except Alexis Verona
just did gorgeous chess he makes his way
into the round of 16.
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real
moves on to the round of 16
trip to the cgc finals and a clean shot
at the largest first place prize of the
year
my friends it's the cgc round of 32. who
will take the next step to Toronto
a look at the legend himself Grandmaster
Peter svidler with a pristine genteel
bookcase made of ancient wood behind
them huge wizard too
says that Fiddler is in an ancient
Library it certainly looks that way well
Peter spieler is taking inspiration from
the books and the memorabilia behind him
and he has brought his A-game to this
match against the Underpants here at the
cgc round of 32 GM Daniel nerdinski
giamamon Hamilton bringing you coverage
of the round of 32 as we pull up our
savidler nepo match-up cardamon
yeah I think it's just pure irony that
of course it's huge wizard that lets us
know about uh svidler's Lair that he's
got there I mean I think they might be
practicing some sort of Witchcraft
together I saw a few spell books in the
back but he's uh certainly doing a good
job so far in this match uh on a serious
note because uh he looks comfortable
he's definitely down on time but who
isn't against the Palm machine you can't
that's not even something that I can say
it doesn't hold any weight everyone is
down on time against this guy I think
when it comes to the matches
nepo is managing the time the way that
he wants to but I think svidler is as
well like he's never been in a situation
where he's needed significantly more
time than he has
no you're totally right he's done a
great job on all fronts so has Maxine
Malikov Let's uh not forget that he is
also an underdog he's a serious Underdog
and he has held his own completely
especially in game one but also in game
two one could argue even putting some
pressure on Lavon uh the only Underdog
who has not had the same good uh good
performance is David Navara he's done
his best but Hikaru Nakamura has been
utterly Unstoppable that last game was a
heartbreaker David Navarro blundering a
knight in an equal Rook end game
although by that point already he was
slightly worse yeah he needs the miracle
The Comeback of the Millennium if he can
come back and win two games and then win
the Armageddon this will probably be the
greatest comeback of all time
it it absolutely will there's no
question about it
um this isn't even two games that could
have gone either way these have been two
hikaranakamura domination games
um and even in the last game which was
so equal he cars still managed to use
something that he had earned over the
course of that game which was a time
Advantage he used it well and he still
came out on top so up two games he
carved with the white pieces we saw how
well that first game went the car was
now going for Queen C2 and Daniel is
this influenced At All by the fact that
he knows he only needs a draw nah why
would you be saying that am I not Queen
C2 it's not really known as one of the
most solid openings against which it's
almost impossible to win
nah nah totally not good thinking about
it at all
but yeah Queen C2 of course but okay in
the very reputable variation uh
how David Navarro will create winning
chances in this position is big question
yes because white is incredibly solid in
this line
big question no answer
um I I think this line has been playing
players probably from both sides I mean
White's winning chances have always been
a grim I think here and Black's winning
chances have uh been few and far between
yeah I mean so so we should point out
that D5 by David isn't necessarily the
main move uh I think most people at this
point Castle but that allows white to
play the move e2e4 fight really wants a
draw E4 basically seals the deal I mean
there's a long theoretical line that
results in a drawn opposite color Bishop
position David going for the immediate
D5 and A3 by Hikaru early A3 a month
that's definitely not the main move I'm
checking opening Explorer just to
confirm Bishop G5 is almost automatic uh
in in the vast majority of top level
games so Hikaru deviating early
and forcing David to make a decision
with his dark squared Bishop
yeah and I'm I'm I was gonna say I
wonder what choice he'll make here
because David also has to keep in mind
that it's a must-win game so he might be
thinking from the perspective of
imbalances yes you can Retreat that
Bishop maybe to D6 maybe to E7 but
there's so many uh available options
there for white to just get a solid game
I think taking the Knight is the right
call now you have a position where yes
you've handed over the two Bishops but
you don't care which side of the
imbalance you have you just want to have
an imbalance the pawn structure is in
Balance maybe a move like you know A5 A4
later for uh for black we might see King
side castling so look it might not be a
greatest but I think Navarro's on the
right path with creating an imbalance
and and just creating it early
yeah he's gotten the kind of position
you want to get I agree completely he's
developed his light squared Bishop to F5
uh posing out a dilemma to Mr Nakamura
now you sometimes see players these
types of positions pushing the pawn
that's F3 I know Ben quiet down uh the
point of this move is to control the E4
score but the downside apart from
weakening the king side is that you're
depriving the Knight of its sort of
rightful developing Square so if Hikaru
wants to play this in a more sort of
milk toast kind of fashion then he can
play Bishop G5 E3 Bishop D3 sort of the
same old stuff and given that he needs
to draw I think Hikaru is more likely to
err on the side of being overly
conservative
agreed I I think that what you
highlighted is a really interesting way
to really neutralize things now there is
a there is a sort of uh I guess a known
thing in the community of uh chess us
chess players Daniel when you try too
hard to trade all the pieces off and go
for a draw you usually end up losing
it's a bad way to play chess chess you
need to be objective at every point and
playing Bishop G5 as white taking the
Knight straight away uh playing Bishop
D3 just just vacuuming all the pieces
objectively not the way to play so you
have to be careful every decision you
make that you know is just not quite the
best move and you know it eventually
that adds up to an advantage that you
might regret later so Hikaru you know
the player that he is and how familiar
he certainly is with what I just talked
about Bishop F4 probably E3 Knight F3
he's just gonna play the game as it's
supposed to be played and uh he's got a
got a great position certainly uh looks
just about equal here two I mean Bishop
pair no Targets in White's position
yeah and as as you know there there are
unbalances here the pawn structure is
interesting there's some meat on the
bone but there there isn't too much of
it I I think hikara was off to a good
start in this game
and you know something something crazy
will have to happen here for David
Navarro to win this he he will he might
have to push C7 C5 at some point but
right now the C7 Pawn is hanging you
can't play C5 and please C6 a month that
just leads to a kind of insipid position
that he's gonna have a hard time winning
maybe something spicier like 94 can be
considered yeah I don't know if you can
get away with a pawn sack at a juncture
this early with your develop and still
not complete yeah that's a good point A
lot of times you can sack this Pawn but
usually there are other pieces on the
board and we're not quite in uh in that
position at the moment so navara's got a
weird decision to make because Pawn to
C6 as you highlighted if you ever go for
castling then suddenly your dark squares
are a lot weaker you went for casting
immediately which means and boy am I
happy to see it uh there's an option for
your car to take that pawn Dania
instinct is he gonna take it no Instinct
this is gonna play E3 yeah just not even
bother right not even also he's going to
calculate it car is not one of those
players who just trusts anything that
his opponent does he plays F3 huh
H5 by Navara whoa
okay those moves are in my mind I would
never predict those two moves
this is very very surprising uh first of
all that's three when you only need you
know a certain a certain result a draw
it's just seems unnecessary but then H5
straight away I mean I feel like I'm an
H5 I feel like I would even consider
maybe like C5 there something like
really really direct after seeing F3 and
before we go to the nepo game which just
started uh
the idea of going G4 it is scary but I'm
on it's not something that I would take
such drastic measures against okay white
plays G4 you dropped the bishop back to
E6 it's not the end of the world and
guess what guess what I don't think
Hikaru would play G4 uh without a good
deal of thought weakening his King side
like that H5 creates a gaping hole on G5
like an entrench a bishop onto that
square if he so desires
I feel like that was a rash that was a
hasty decision by David and now Hikaru
is quickly going to complete his
kingside development
and I I think White's better here
agreed
okay so we have the other two games are
underway levana ronian repeating his
opening from game one The Bishop's
opening will go to that game shortly but
first let's check in as is our tradition
to the smidler nepo game oh
juice for that
let's check in with Fiddler nepo I
believe because that game that we just
saw right there we can't predict any
moves of Dania so let's head somewhere
where we can actually call the moves a
little bit better than that one because
look if if you're putting me in the
commentary booth and you're saying yes
uh the next couple moves and it's f3h5
Queen East I look I'm sorry I've not cut
out for this so uh look I'm happy to be
here Dania e45 nice I'm covering yeah
this is the traditional well-known you
know plain vanilla Roy Lopez position
yeah the kind we all feel comfortable in
now
what bitters Fiddler has uh carried out
here is a line that has become
significantly more popular in recent
months I know Magnus Carlson has been
testing it out it's this weird thing
where if we rewind a little bit Bishop
C5 is totally normal this is I think the
Archangel but in most cases
traditionally black plays B5 into six
who needs D6 I'm on who needs to open up
their light squared Bishop at all eh
that's what that's what the old guys do
the cool kids don't do that anymore
Bishop C2 and D5 in one Fell Swoop
finally there it is such an important
move to play uh for the minor pieces and
blacks but just getting things open up
that d-pawn stuck on D7 is uh is simply
the worst so many times you see in this
opening if white gets to play D5 before
black does then you know it's uh it's
kind of trouble
um but what we see here is definitely a
position I would say well especially
after CF6 that I'm happy with if I'm
nepo
has Peter svidler infected whatever has
plagued tikaru and David whatever that
you know that condition is where it's a
compulsion to move your kingside pawns
what what is it is this Theory wait a
minute
Fiddler is the one in 15 minutes
okay I'm kidding let me say that again
smidler has 15 minutes Napo has 13
minutes
yeah the first time you said it I
legitimately didn't believe you you
repeat that you can do you confuse your
pronouns like did you mean to say Nepal
where you said Spindler no no there's
the one in 15 minutes this must be
preparation must yeah
yeah no doubt about it
um now that being said this is the kind
of preparation that sometimes you even
need to be a little bit careful with
like it's the kind of preparation as
black that I would go over you know with
the the magnifying glass maybe five six
times just to make sure that I know what
I'm doing after because the thing with
preparation is once it ends you don't
want to be clueless you don't want to
get to this position and then you know
Nepal plays Knight D2 and you're like uh
okay great I did my prep right this was
this was correct I did it okay but I
don't love the position I've got a weak
d-pawn on D6 a Target on the open file
I've got weak light squares because I
played G5 you know if I play G4 the
Knight might slide into H4 into F5 so I
think this is a position that uh
spiddler definitely needs to have looked
at before I'm sure he has so he's just
taking his time and and establishing
what he's gonna do next but honestly
this plays really nicely for white
yeah I mean it's so easy to be
influenced by the evil bar you see the
zeros and you say this is a dead draw no
I mean there's a lot of imbalances the
biggest asset for black arguably is the
bishop pair and the fact that this dark
squid Bishop is so nicely tucked in on
A7 it's safe it's secure and it's
controlling a lot of key Central squares
so I think that white really needs to
try to step on the gas pedal in the next
couple of moves while black still is
sort of completing his development
getting the Rooks into the game you've
got to try to put that I-94 you've been
indicating some of the ideas here
quickly go Rook do you want to go after
the D6 Pawn because that is the only you
know concrete appreciable Target in
Black's position so I think we're going
to see 94 by yawn on the next move or
maybe Knight C4 and Peter's gonna try to
figure out how to arrange where to put
his other Bishop first of all E6 or G4
and and how to arrange the Rooks do you
put them on dude E8 or do you find uh
something a little bit more creative
here
yeah I that's a pretty good summary
honestly because I I think both players
are calculating exactly that at the
moment Fiddler the one spending time and
nepo the thing is like Knight bd2 is his
last move he's got the easier game he's
got the target he knows where his pieces
belong I think Fiddler is the one that
has more to prove in this position so
even though this is preparation from
svidler I have to say like I'd be pretty
happy as nepo here
no I would
I would be totally satisfied nepo likes
positions in which he feels comfortable
he feels that he knows the ideas
um another idea by the way which Peter
could be contemplating is the move D5 as
Brazen as it seems to just push your
weak Pawn even further down the board
as I talk about it he's just amazing not
so Brazen it restricts the night the
night no longer has access to these two
squares and Bishop B3 was nicely met
with Bishop E6 that's why nepo instantly
plays rookie one covering the E6 square
and the battle is going to rage over
Winterfell over that pawn on D5
yeah and again it's that classic
frustration rookie one played and it's
like the movie We're counting on next
probably Bishop E6 immediately stops so
it's just that little bit of frustration
there Bishop G4 I think has the
intention of just guarding the d-pawn
with the rook and maybe bring that
Bishop around the other way like Bishop
H5
yes
and if black can get D4 in and a good
version then we won't even be talking
about a potential pull for white we
might be talking about uh a position
that is to be preferred for black
because Miller still has that Bishop
pair that's right that's right yeah D4
is really what has to be contained here
by Napo Bishop G4 also doing an another
important job which is it's kind of
stopping the move Knight B3 Knight B3
white wants to maybe Shuffle that Night
Out cover the D4 Square play Rook D1 and
establish a knight there but Bishop
takes F3 could be thrown in those pawns
do not look great and that could end up
in immediate liquidation and a draw
which at this point in the match nepo
really really does not want I mean think
about it three draws he's gonna have the
black pieces in the final game anything
can happen in one individual game so
something like Knight B3 Bishop takes F3
is something that NEPA will only resort
to if he really does not find any ways
of you know keeping keeping some meat on
the bone in this position
uh talk about a lack of meat on the bone
I'm going to be totally honest here I'm
on the levonne aronian match has been a
little bit underwhelming we haven't been
spending as much time and it's not be
out of disrespect to Lavon or Maxime
these are amazing players but every time
I look at the position they're in some
sort of an end game so let us go to that
game just to update everybody on the
position but it is yet another
uh Knight versus Bishop end game what do
you make of this maybe this one is a
little bit better for white
right
um you know is it the amount of
betterness that is needed probably not
um but it does look a little bit better
I would have to agree
um solid Pawn structure for white he
just got rid or he's in the process of
getting rid of his third Pawn Island so
what will remain are just the two Pond
Islands the H3 G2 pawns and ones on the
queen side and yeah I was gonna say
interesting choice of which Pawn to win
yeah because you could oh actually maybe
you couldn't you probably could have won
you could have played Rook F5 and taken
on E5 but then the structure would be
really symmetrical at least now there's
a bit of an imbalance here
yeah I I was actually expecting Rook E1
and uh if King E7 Rook F4 but instead
he's he's kind of gone for taking the C7
pawn and saying look the e-pawn is still
weak I can win that one whenever winning
the C7 Pawn would have been impossible
to do later and you know you took the
only opportunity he had uh to grab it
while he could and black is experiencing
some logistical
some logistical problems here if you
play F6 let's bring up an analysis word
real fast just to show that it's not all
that easy for black to keep all of his
pawns protective keep his bases covered
Rook C6 bang bang
hates that move but
this is not an easy position to go for
last time I checked black is down a pawn
here
uh yeah that that's this is just a case
of the you know the engine being so
comfortable being down upon its full
counter attack I guess
and look at this line Rook D2 let me try
to win White's Queen side bonzers Rooks
the eight check dropping that Rook on AJ
these are the consequences of not being
fully developed even though it's the end
game white still has an initiative
because his pieces are more actively
positioned I think this is a big
opportunity for Lavon he's up five
minutes on the clock or so he's got
definitely without question an end game
pull
and things seem to be getting worse for
Maxime who drops the pawn on E5 and sees
nothing better than
to just acquiesce to a pawn down and
game I'm on this is trouble for for Mr
Malikov and Rook DT Rook E2 first move
that I think of here just to cover the
second rank watch over that C2 Pawn
there's always going to be pawns hanging
take a look at the H6 pawn and the B6
Pawn in Black's position some Rook C6
move is you know later down the line
it's gonna hit both of those pawns uh I
think uh this position is trending in
aronian's favor I think there hasn't
been much between them in this match
Dania which it actually it just
heightens it makes this every individual
game means so much if you can get a win
here as aronian the way the match is
gone that's a huge Edge that's not just
like a turbulent match where both sides
are winning and now it's your turn this
is a dead even match hasn't been
anything between them so one win that's
enough to maybe win the whole thing yeah
you just get the sense that the players
have not been able to create too many
chances with the white pieces you're
absolutely right Lavon is up upon he's
going to continue
milking and pushing this position in the
meantime the Hikaru Nakamura David
Navarro game continues uh to get crazier
and more heated so I think this is a
perfect opportunity to jump back to that
game
and this is what we currently have on
the board so navara's task this game was
to unbalance the position create some
Intrigue I think he's done that the
problem I'm on is that he's unbalanced
it in the sense that he's worse white
has a center in Black doesn't
yeah you have the advantage and I don't
and so the game is in Balance now
um Mission success what do they say task
failed successfully something like that
just fail successfully yeah exactly I
think here
um you know if the match was in a
different situation I would be talking a
little bit more about oh you know
hikaru's done a great job he's got great
chances on the king Side based on the
match it's it's actually the advantage
that I think Hikaru has that is gonna be
enough
to get him a draw uh he only needs a
draw and just because he's actually
pushing here
I think it's going to be too much for
for Navara to uh to handle and you know
even E5 Knight D6 here
is doing exactly that and C4 by the way
it's just hanging yeah hanging Queen G5
is about to magically appear on the
board oh this is this is nasty this is
disgusting I mean I again let's not
forget that David has to somehow win
this position that's not happening this
one's over so it it looks like Hikaru is
in a great spot in this match it the
position unless a you know draw or
Perpetual kind of presents itself it
might not even really be possible or for
Trotta even happens so we might just see
Hikaru actually win the third game and
win the match we have seen a little bit
of 3-0 in this competition right Dania
in the global Championship we have seen
some three O's not too many granted
every match has been pretty close but it
does happen and uh oftentimes the third
win is just a product of you know that
player needing desperately to win and so
taking more risks than usual and it's
and it's a statement that you're making
for for subsequent rounds I mean not
that Hikaru has to make any additional
statements everybody knows who they're
up against yeah uh but but he's gonna
play the board he's not gonna go out of
his way to liquidate into an equal end
game when he's winning in the middle
game right he's not afraid of having the
Queens on the board uh no all of a
sudden no he's not so did David's still
trying that 94 you know threatening the
pawn on E5 so
not to suggest that white doesn't have
to be careful here if you play Queen G5
you might run into G6 and I mean
obviously there's some smothered made
ideas so still still some clouds that
ikara has to navigate through
yeah yeah this one is not over but
Hikaru is rather technical when he needs
to be and you know he
smells that he's got the edge and there
might be a tactic that that he should be
looking for I mean generally he'll Spot
It
no 100 percent
um okay well we can leave him
uh to continue converting his Advantage
which of the other two games do do you
have the Jones for uh I think we should
check back to this into this Fiddler
again because we have some really
interesting developments there Yana is
worse
yeah so I think I'm just gonna say this
is I was gonna say that one as well so
we're on the same page let's oh Queen G5
played and before we do that hang on a
second we gotta respect the eval bar
it's uh it's telling us to stay at least
for one more move right because really
crucial where or how the car reacts to
this move G6 no no 100 I think I think
we will all be forgiven for sticking
around a little while longer H3 now it
might be the case that Hikaru has
spotted some sort of a liquidation into
a draw exactly what I said he's unlikely
to do if he sees a slam dunk way to get
a position he knows he won't lose yeah
uh then he'll do it Knight takes E5 I
think Knight H6 check
or Rook takes D5 and Knight h6s is
what and then just because he'll just
grab the the C Pawn at the end
oh yeah and it's just a draw Knight H6
Queen takes E5 and Rook takes C4 yeah
great decision making why not yeah a
great example of playing the match
rather than always trying to play the
board
um
Hikaru is you know an expert at that he
doesn't need more than to draw and he so
this is kind of what I was alluding to
earlier I was saying his position is so
good that I always see him making a draw
or being equal if he needs to be so he
used that that edge that he had and he
basically gave it away in exchange for
you know a bunch of pieces flying off
the board and suddenly it simplified so
much that the draw is essentially
imminent
it is and Rook takes C4 is on the
horizon perhaps sicaro contemplating an
initial check on effort to send the king
back to G7 I don't think it makes a
critical difference b-a-b-a Queen B1 by
the way is a total paper tiger the king
always has a nice Escape score on H2 it
always seems like Hikaru has made lufts
I don't even remember when he played H3
and yet it always seems like he's got
that move included precisely when he
needs it to be included exactly
magically there
everything is perfect he actually just
played it by the way to attack the
Knight on G4 so of course all in stride
from Hikaru and well I think we can
safely say this looks like two and a
half Target score will be reached at
minimum which is enough to win this
match and knock out David Navarro from
this competition indeed it is we will
keep an eye on this game and let you
know when it officially finishes but now
I think is a good time to jump to this
Fiddler game
in which Peter svidler has not only
managed to eradicate the weakness on T5
but he's managed to make the most of his
Bishop air he is most certainly in the
driver's seat in this position but not
necessarily more than that I don't think
that nepo will have too much trouble
holding his own here still scary scary
stuff for yawn
yeah I think it's very great you know uh
nepo's nepo's backseat driving still a
little bit uh Peter offers a draw though
well I uh I think it's an interesting
decision considering a few things Dania
uh and I will use this moment to be ever
so slightly critical
um there's not first of all I don't
think we've seen the time uh this even
this late into the game so he's still
got five minutes and change lots to play
for it
um the other thing is it's one of the
best positions that he's had all game
and you know when you when you work that
hard to get there and then just offer a
draw you're not really you're not really
celebrating properly
um when you have the best position that
you've had all game you should probably
play it out a little bit because
well you know logic would State Daniel
that if you have the best position
you've had all game your opponent
probably has the worst position they've
had all game and in that situation I'm
going to switch by the way to the irony
game as you as yeah let's switch go
ahead let's switch uh because that
game's done but go ahead honestly like I
I think in in that situation
you just can't do your opponent any
favors it's the worst thing in chess
like you have to think nepho's probably
sitting there not liking his position at
all and you're just gonna repeat moves
to give him a draw you guys over the
moon he said oh thanks like my position
was actually starting to really be
unpleasant and you uh you know smack me
with a draw offer right when that
happens it's a good feeling I'd only
should be that kind to your uh your
opponents that being said it's not a
terrible result of course but I think I
think he could have done a little bit
more it's not like he was up against the
wall time pressure or anything like that
I I agree I think that's uh that's a
good explanation of why you think uh
playing would have been the more prudent
option the speed with which nepo took
that dropper is another indication of
that nepo does like not accept raw as in
equal positions right he only takes them
if he feels there's imminent danger
as you're saying so okay obviously the
match situation is really good for Peter
right absent is all of these
considerations if you came up to him and
said Peter
we can make this four game match into a
one game match in which you have the
white pieces basically like an
Armageddon game maybe we'll have an
actual Armageddon game he would accept
that offer with open arms so this is the
most danger that nepo has been in match
was in the cgc obviously and in the RCC
and really the last like seven
tournaments that he's played so
we are in for a treat ladies and
gentlemen but first will levonaronian
convert his extra Pawn I think the
answer is increasingly looking
like it will be no what do you think
Rook uh E6 Knight C4 and yeah you're
kind of pointing to A4 being the move
I I'm gonna take the contrarian view and
say like no I know imagine imagine us
being on the contrarian view where is
our unified front I'm telling you Dania
look I I'm ready to have your back but
when it comes to the Von aronian I just
find him to be so Technical and you know
he just squeezes the life out of
everything aronian is not the kind of
guy I think to
to have this game end very quickly so
the very least I think we'll try to play
it out and with a minute and a half for
Matt lakov anything can happen
no of course I in all seriousness I do
agree I think point five is a serious
underestimation of the Practical chances
that Levon holds in this position
because it's not like if Maxine defends
for 10 moves then magically it's already
a draw Lavon can torture him add
infinitive you can play 50 moves if you
want to play 50 moves you can play 50
moves and then push the pawn to F4
that's right so so Maxime is in for the
Long Haul he's going to have to avoid
missing Forks you think 2700 missing a
fork well that Knight on E5 we've seen
crazier things happen than a GM missing
a fork with a minute left on his clock
after an already strenuous period of
Defending so
I'm gonna give this a 50 50 chance I
think I can see Maxine holding this but
I can also see a blunder happening or
maybe Lavon finding a way to get his
Pawn eventually to F6 let's Buckle in
strap ourselves in and
watch the show King will come back to G4
to defend the pawn
obviously I'm on I'll finish by saying
that the ideal scenario is where black
gives up the bishop for both of White's
pawns but that ain't gonna happen
levon's not gonna allow that to happen
no and as you say that he actually
cements one of his pawns onto a dark
square and that will ensure that that
basically is never possible
um Bishop E6 and I mean first thing that
comes to mind in my head is like pinning
that that bishop and the other thing
that I'm thinking about is can we
actually pin the bishop and get a
position where black runs out of Moves
Like Rook A6 Rook A7 check H5 I want to
get my knight to G4
yeah Knight G4
is a very unpleasant Prospect if black
loses H6 even if a rook trade happens I
think it's lost
wait what happened there is it winning
oh Rook A6
yeah oh my God I'm on Rook a16 G7 hg4
sorry we should break up an analysis
board here this is winning
Rook g6h5
and if Bishop takes G4 the pawn end game
is lost
so
unintentionally like I just kind of you
missed it I said those moves Knight G4
H5 Rook A6 but I didn't realize they
could all be put in the pot right now I
said all of them we didn't realize that
was the that was the recipe Daniel it
didn't occur to me come on but this is
he's got to see that Rook A6 is obvious
right you're pinning the bishop what he
missed what he missed was obviously
Knight G4 exactly but he's got to see
that he's got plenty of time
that's and he's a really really big Miss
from both players but yes more so on
Lavon with the extra time and you know
he's the one trying to win
um he's got to be on the lookout for
those it's tougher as a Defender to spot
everything I don't get it I mean LeBron
this is precisely the kind of trick that
he's trying to set up he got got it
served on a golden platter and he just
stubbornly keeps this Rook on the
seventh rank giving Maxime a new lease
on life for malachov the strategy is
just basically to wait on the sixth rank
uh and you know wait for Lavon to pose
concrete threats white can push the pawn
to F4 right that's not a problem but how
are you going to get that pawn any
further than F4 that might have been the
golden opportunity yeah something tells
me he's gonna get another one
yeah it just I think in in positions
like this what you want to do as Lavon
is pretend like you're trying really
cool ideas and that pretending you know
takes 30 seconds off both of your clocks
and then everything that you were
previously doing is magnified because
the time is lower
no totally
yeah everything is Scary or every threat
more deadly with 30 seconds and Maxime
is burning through his clock right he is
not breaking even with that two second
increment that's right okay
those last couple of moves came a long
way though
um there's maybe knight c293 uh Knight's
kind of good there as for this
rookie seven rookie five is it I was
gonna ask you is it out of the question
I asked you first yeah yeah it's
unfortunate oh I asked you back but I
was told
to answer a question with a question
yeah let's pass that one over the chat
there
um my my instinct is uh is that I
wouldn't do it because I don't need to
and if I've played 40 moves moved upon
if I played 40 more moves and it's a
long game I might do that later but I
don't need to commit to that right now
that alleviates maybe a lot of the hard
work that I want to make my opponent do
I love that feeling when you're
defending for forever like some Pawn
down Rook end game and finally your
opponent just like goes into a
Philadelphia position which is basically
a draw for that relief you feel like now
I know how to draw this lavon's not
gonna give Maxi Malika the luxury of
that feeling until another 50 moves have
passed exactly this is what I was
talking about earlier with this Fiddler
game I was saying don't be too nice to
your opponents they're not going to be
nice to you uh and when they're in a
tough position don't let them out of it
with a draw offer or no repetition or
trade uh keep them in those tough
positions because they don't want to be
there I can't believe you Mr Rook A6 I I
usually I almost always give the player
the benefit of the doubt we've all been
in this situation we know how hard it is
to find a resource on demand we know
that when the eval bar screams plus
seven it's so much easier
but all of that aside that was an
elementary move and you know you can't
normally miss these types of chances in
the cgc and expect to get away with it
agreed but maybe he will Rook A3 great
move
yeah really powerful actually and when
you move those pawns up to dark squares
I think the issue becomes well all of a
sudden the bishop on the light squares
it just controls everything and there's
no restricting that Bishop any longer
no this is I think just a dead Drive I
think Lavon has to take on H3 because if
he tries to go the other way which he
did uh you're actually gonna end up
losing the Knight after King E4 Bishop
G2 he literally at this point is out of
options he's gonna try to win the H6
spawn so we might actually get an f and
H Pawn Rook end game which I mentioned
in a previous game after all I don't
remember in what context I think it was
the swiddler nepo game
um it was actually that game and we were
saying like oh it's gonna be a draw but
actually if you take every Pawn off the
board it's still a draw
nice and little cafe it's much easier
but still not great I wouldn't be
shocked if black loses this game Rook C6
and King F5 is on Deck come on yeah and
it's unpleasant
oh
okay so Rook A3 right not attacking the
F Pawn so all of a sudden white says
okay sure we're okay four may be as
accurate I don't know
three
two seconds
the thing is as black you don't even
have to win the pawn right you could
just play Rook G3 there and I think
you're still drawing exactly you have a
safety a safety net even if you blunder
H6 you're okay but you're not going to
because F4 cannot be easily defended
yeah this is uh well done here Maxim
declines the repetition
yeah good you're playing on for the win
of course
Maybe Game Gear six King G6
though King G6 is it feels too easy for
black allowing that
no Lavon is going to be heartbroken when
he figures out
the chance that he missed back to G7
goes mountlakeoff and the side checks
them on are always so so annoying to
faces the attacking side yep from the
long side as well what
you can repeat F5 what is that move what
is work H5 that's an insane Rook C7 and
F6 and the king is pushed back to the
back rank this is what how could you do
that I don't understand just lost his
ever loving mind F6 is coming it's over
he had to draw he's right in front of
him he was playing it three-time
repetition literally what did he just do
oh my God to promote it's a win Rook G8
and it's only sunk in now but he's got
two seconds for that reality and look at
this
zigzagging his way down to E2 this
is unbelievable at the last hurdle all
he had to do was repeat make that same
move
he already did the hard work of finding
the move he's already got it just do it
again G6 that's it no more way to
progress I think Lavon would literally
have taken the draw
yeah honestly there's nothing else to do
no H5 no F5 but why are you suddenly
going for this meaningless Pawn the
entire point of this end game is to
prevent the progress of the F1 that is
precisely what he doesn't do with that
move I can't believe what we just saw
that is a shocker Dania because he it's
not like even if Rook H5 was also
drawing why you've already founded your
your drawing method just keep doing it
I'm I'm absolutely Blown Away by that
move and he might have just cost himself
his spot in this competition as he's now
down we bring up these scores for the
matches he's now down to LaVon aronian
in a match where you could hardly find
anything between these two players and
now there's a full point and now not
only do you have to recover mentally but
you have to win on demand against Lavon
which is hard even if you are in the
best of moods and the best of mental
places this is going to be a
ridiculously tall order I can't believe
what we just saw and it's just another
day here at the cgc this has been epic
and the greatest part is that we have an
amazing game between nepo and siddler
coming up that matches all tied up and
we're gonna see if Maxime matlokov can
recover after this shocking shocking
blunder before we go on break we wanted
to remind you that if you are a product
manager if you're at work and watching
chess right now on company time then
first of all shame on you just kidding
uh we need you we need you to help
coordinate events like POG Champs the
speed Chess Championship the cgc and
more Type X clamp p-m-o-e exclaim
p-m-o-e in chat for all details and
combine your passions in the love of
Chess on the world's greatest scene be a
product manager for chess.com and right
now be strapped into your seats because
game four and smidler nepo and aronian
Malikov is coming right up here at the
cgc stay tuned for game four on the
other side of this short break
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
ER here on a beautiful Saturday
afternoon watching the 2022 chess.com
Global Championship alongside the one
and only chess brought Grandmaster Amman
Hamilton it's been a barn burner in all
three of our matches one of them already
concluded big surprise him on the Hikaru
Nakamura seals the deal after only three
games against David Navarro the other
two matches have been very close a
shocking blunder by Maxime he goes down
a point nepo against Fiddler is our
Marquee matchup it is all tied up and it
goes down to the wire who Amman will
make their way to the final eight in
Toronto
yeah it's a great question I mean at
this point we know Hikaru has done a
great job he's informed in this
tournament he dispatched with of David
Navarra two and a half to half and you
know it I feel like sometimes I say it
really didn't paint the picture this
time I feel like it did Hikaru was
dominant on top start to finish and you
know uh he's done after three games as
he deserves to be playing like that uh
the Palm machine's Fiddler it's been
even the whole way we might even go to
an Armageddon so we'll be closely
watching that match up and finally Lavon
aronian will take that gift from his
opponent Maxim matlikov and now he can
put things away with with a draw and if
he puts things away Daniel of course he
gets even closer to that that first
place uh prize fund of course we've got
the uh overall one million dollars in
total prizes and two hundred thousand
dollars for the champion this year Dan
yeah David Navarra he will take home ten
thousand dollars so The Losers of the
other two matches but two hundred
thousand dollars is the top prize so
it's not just five thousand dollars
that's on the line it is potentially 190
000. that final eight will be contested
in the great City of Toronto Canada
in November early November it's gonna be
epic you are not going to want to miss
it and it is going to feature all of the
greatest and brightest nicest most
handsome faces on the chess.com team
November 2nd through 7th will be the cgc
championship I know a certain Canadian
Grandmaster will be there
nobody else lives in Toronto and I'm
easily the most famous person here so oh
it's absolutely my city
no it's nothing else is happening I
can't recognize any of the other faces
particularly not that I don't know why
that guy's so big the one in the blue
shirt get him out of here he should be
as Tiny as Lawrence Trent is in this
photo
exactly yeah no we need more prominent
feature for that guy right in the middle
that guy in the back clearly being
modest
um you know letting letting everyone
else shine
oh my goodness well the games we have
two games remember the Hikaru game the
Hikaru match is over they will not play
the fourth game so we have nepo Fiddler
and aronian matlakov we saw Maxie
Malikov on camera there during the break
he is in there we see him on camera now
fuming upset I do not know it is beyond
me how you push that crazy blunder away
from you especially after you survived
you know giving Levon a chance to play
Rook A6 you survived that and then you
wonder at the last hurdle heartbreaking
no it really is
um this game will be I mean it's tough
to bounce back that's the thing it's one
thing to need a win you know under the
gun you've got the white pieces at least
but it's quite another when you're still
reeling hopefully he's not from the
blunder that you just made to put
yourself in this position you shouldn't
even be here in your mind
yeah this would be a time match you've
got the white pieces that's a great
situation
this changes everything like seen with
an early A3
that is not a move
I have seen in this particular position
now I'm on it's a very typical idea to
prepare D take C5 followed by B4 that's
not atypical but to do it here is kind
of odd
it certainly is like A3 is such a modest
move but it actually has a bit of a
punch to it and I have never seen this
setup
G3 E3 A3 B4 Knight bd2
yeah that's that's a lot of stuff but I
guess the the more you see of it the
more you can kind of understand at least
what is being prepared here but dc5 B4
is what medlock's trying to trying to do
but E5 byronian is probably stunned him
a little bit because he's been preparing
C4
he's been preparing C4 now that move is
impossible
so the for Maxime the general strategy
of getting a non-theoretical position
with a lot of pieces on the board that's
all that you can possibly ask for with
the white pieces and they must win game
but with C4 impossible does he have to
resort to maybe D take C5 and E4 or
maybe B4 followed by E4 hard to say
which Pawn he's going to push to the
fourth rank
yeah but he he does have to lay claim to
some space
um if he doesn't I mean he's just gonna
have no chances in this game now the the
choice is actually back on Lavon because
if he closes things up with the move C4
all of a sudden it hands over E4 to
White which is not possible now because
of depression on the receiving end of
that I hate it like I hate playing C4
and then E4 E5 and I feel like my Center
is collapsing
that's right no it's really
uncomfortable I think Levant would
prefer to play moves that you're
highlighting like the deal with the
b-pawn without playing C4 Queen V6 A6
um even potentially something like B4
all those moves make they make a little
bit more sense than C4 to me while C4
might be a good move I think that he
doesn't really want to commit that
structure yeah no you're absolutely
right he plays actually C takes D4 first
and now the move A5 of course the pawn
on B5 is no longer hanging because uh of
the Tactical Knight takes D4 so uh Lavon
is more than happy to leave this Pawn on
pre for the time being and the point of
flying A5 I think is prophylaxis against
uh the solidifying move C3 now C3 is
going to encounter B4 and with the queen
side exploding like that white could end
up being saddled with a serious weakness
on C3 you sometimes see this in the Karo
Khan uh you see this Pawn structure in
quite a few openings and I think Lavon
is doing a great job of choosing an
ultra solid setup with no weaknesses
which is going to make it so hard for
maxim uh to press this to Victory
exactly
um it's hard not to play C3 so I think
you will end up doing that yeah he does
and we see that we see the move C3 just
because B4 is intended doesn't mean that
this can't be met this way uh one
interesting way that you could play is C
takes B4 so if you want to pull up an
analysis board like C takes B4 a takes
B4 uh A4 and then look it's like not
great but if I can claim that I've got
this passed on for later in the game
that's at least a permanent advantage
and I can try to play around it
um hey this is a must win game for
Maxine so I would always be on the
lookout for permanent things that I can
you know save for later yeah back we go
to the live position he's basically done
the same thing on the other side he's
put a b a b and C4 rather than c b a b
and A4
and this also looks very sensible to me
if I had to assess the position I would
assign definitely a pull a pull to White
even though black is incredibly solid uh
you know the Bishops on E7 and D7 don't
exactly make the you know the most uh I
was gonna say impressive impression uh
but they don't exactly breathe fear into
uh maximum outlookov's mind here and I
think if he goes B3 and Bishop B2 and
maybe 95 maybe I spoke too soon maybe it
is very much possible to start squeezing
black in the center here C5 though
committal but also totally
understandable establishing a protected
past Pawn no question that white is
slightly better here
yeah absolutely
um the one thing about this position as
we see Brook A8 is it all comes down to
you know can black play the move E5
eventually or Target the d-pawn for
white and anyway because if that d-pawn
falls uh moves gets traded anything all
of the above the C Pawn you'll notice is
just a Sitting Duck that's C Pawn for
white needs the pawn on D4 and the pawn
on D4 therefore needs all the attention
all the pampering right gotta hold on to
that yeah it's and uh you know and
without it you're you're dead this is
like the pawn on C5 is like me doing uh
labs and high school science like I I
knew how to do a good write-up and so
I'd get a good grade but you know who's
doing all the work you know who's doing
the actual experiments it's that pawn on
D4 that's what's really keeping the
engine running here yeah and that is
exactly why Maxine positions his Knight
on V3 a purely defensive posture uh but
like you're saying it is critically
important to a defend D4 and B make sure
that you're controlling the E5 square
and preventing a central breakthrough
yep the other thing that the Knight does
really well is it covers A1 so white has
ideas like Bishop F4 Bishop E3 uh and
Rook slides over to A1 to take over the
a file so I think it's fair to say Dania
that madlikov has got a good position
All Things Considered uh he needs a win
in this game at all all costs I think he
set himself up reasonably well yeah but
now he's got to push aside that regret
that voice which tells him hey if I had
drawn that previous game and I had this
position
I would have already been on the cusp
you know of maybe winning getting to the
round of 16. now even if he wins he
forces an Armageddon so all of those
negative disappointing thoughts we all
have them after a disappointing result
but so far he's done a great job of
avoiding tilt playing objectively you're
gonna have to keep that going as Lavon
threatens the Knight on B3 the nepo game
will be starting momentarily and once it
does we'll bring you the opening from
that game as I speak it has begun so I'm
on with your permission let's switch
over to the nepo game
uh uh you have it now all right you were
thinking about it okay
and in English bye mistress Fiddler
who yeah as you mentioned this probably
did factor into his decision in the
previous game to take that draw because
he knew okay I'll be heading into the
the last game and uh I'll have the white
pieces which is always Pleasant for
anyone as we see the English opening
very trendy line these days and it's
it's actually kind of feels like a uh
you know accelerated hyper accelerated
Dragon like the opposite the opposite
colors well we saw Sam sebion defeating
Maxima Sheila grav in a beautiful
American game precisely in this line
although I think they've already
deviated from that game you said it this
is all the rage everybody's playing this
line now
yeah D3 hitting the the pawn on e4 and
already there's stuff hanging right D4
if if you're looking at the Knight on D4
well right now it's actually hanging
completely it is White's turn but that's
a serious threat
yep but you can take it now anyway and a
lot of people
would probably wonder why black can't
just tried everything I think it has to
do with giving white the bishop pair in
an open position right yes white will
have an isolated Pawn on D4 but giving
away the dark squared Bishop this early
with the center being wide open it's a
I'm not saying it's bad but it's very
committal and Jan commits to it yeah I
think this is heading toward a draw come
on
we see it on the board this is exciting
uh I I generally like what black does in
these Bishop E6 Knight D7 D6 yeah
you know it's really really equal but if
I had to pick a side I would probably
take nepo and
um I I guess this brings me to another
point which I'm curious what you think
as well but you know this isn't like one
of those matches where you play Four
games of one time control and then maybe
tie breaks in a shorter time control and
then maybe a shorter time control and
then Armageddon this is for games
straight to Armageddon and it really
feels to me like the higher rated player
might not want to go into this whole
Armageddon bidding process like kind of
wild decider
um do you feel like it's it's something
that they should be considering or are
you okay with the idea that the the
Armageddon game which feels like more of
a coin flip than the other games it
seems like they're just walking into it
I don't think it's possible to debate
that the Armageddon produces more upsets
and is more of a coin flip Peter
offering a draw with the move Bishop G5
though so I think that's totally
consistent with his strategy he wants a
coin flip he knows he's the underdog he
wants this uh to get into a crazy
Armageddon time scramble where anything
can happen Jan is contemplating it so
from Nepal's perspective going Knight
bd7 and saying let me make a couple more
moves let me try to decide this in an
orderly fashion makes a lot of sense and
there he goes Knight bd7 the draw for is
declined but I'm on Pablo pencaradov he
upset vishian on where Armageddon Sammy
where did he beat MBL Armageddon so
Armageddon breeds uncertainty it breeds
crazy results and I think both players
are operating consistent with their
strategy yon wants to make a push Peter
wants this to get into an Armageddon but
if I'm honest I don't see yon winning
this game white is just too solid you've
got the bishop bear you're basically
ready to play D5 and liquidate all of
the minor pieces off the board
yeah that that's what I was gonna point
out oftentimes you'll see like a move a
draw for it declined and then maybe
that's okay and then the other guy's
like all right okay listen that draw for
totally you know we misfired there we
actually do want to draw this game
yeah I always remember a a regular at my
chess club in San Francisco he was about
2100 he always had the weirdest way of
offering draws like you wouldn't just
say Alfred draw he would basically he
would say something like all right you
want to call it a day
all right let's go grab some coffee
shall we and that would basically mean
let's call it a draw and he would do
that even if he's worse so he would try
to rope people in to accepting draws
yeah because it sounds more friendly
like oh yeah let's grab a beer after the
game like yeah exactly exactly yeah a
lot of people were in fools but I think
nepo is probably seriously considering
reciprocating that draw for right about
now yeah literally in this moment
because he sees D5 coming it could be D5
right away it could be Bishop takes
Knight and then Pawn to D5 point is I
don't think you can stop the move no
and just to give you okay maybe H6 is
the most prudent option otherwise if you
get a bishop versus knight situation
then White's gonna be the one declining
the drive we bring up an analysis report
let's say black castles you play D5 CD
Knight T5 Knight T5 Bishop D5 you trade
everything
all of a sudden NEPA will be will be
asking himself why exactly did I not
take the drug here I am worse the bishop
is better than the knight in an open
board so
you know it's important to be smart here
for nepo
indeed he's like he's a he's a very
talented player but maybe sometimes not
the most uh objective or practical
because uh you know he's just got that
confidence instilled in himself someone
offers him a draw immediate reaction is
like no get that out of my voice what
are you talking about no wait you want
to draw well now I don't you know it's
like when you hear your sibling oh and
there's the draw for is it a draw for by
uh let's give ourselves another pat on
the back we like called that retired
psychological sequence we are in their
heads they are in each other's heads and
they are now going to an R Maia done
we broke that down nicely
go team
um but yeah that that honestly is
probably what was going on and we are
going to see uh what should be an
extremely exciting Armageddon game but
not before the uh the other match that
we have ongoing
um you know wraps itself up indeed and
this one will go to Armageddon if Maxine
matlikov wins this position on demand
he's got the white pieces he lost in a
heartbreaker if you're just joining us
in the previous game he did everything
to draw a losing Rook end game only to
stumble at the very last moment when
Lavon had already acquiesced to a
repetition to move so what's going on
here Maxime is trying to get
92. oh I was are you as surprised as I
was expecting Bishop D2 and Rook A1
exactly yeah um that's what I've sort of
been calling for
um is Bishop
D2 is there a problem with Bishop D2 yes
like looks fine to me I think maybe he
was worried about 94.
but 94 is nothing to be worried about I
mean Rook A1 and Bishop B1 and if we can
bring up an analysis board here like
this type of position I think white is
significantly better and exactly
F3 if you need it you know you can play
Knight D2 later so what the heck
is it Queen A2 like uh sorry on Bishop
D2 Bishop
and it's like you try to I don't know
it's just like a weird position where
yeah you can take B4 but you take B2 as
well
no it's a puzzling move by Maxime yeah
no I don't think there's any way around
it the Knight I thought was so well
placed on B3 supporting Rook A1 yes you
want to get to the E5 square but you
know I I think handing black the a file
like this is something he might come to
regret
yeah I agree completely Knight D7 is a
prophylactic measure
by aronian to stop the knight from
getting to E5 perhaps Maxime could try
to some Shenanigans with Bishop H3 and
he does this threatens the obvious
Bishop takes E6 and guess what levant's
king is not the safest piece on the
board if he plays King h8 maybe the
queen kind of worms its way into F4
maybe even a g Pawn March if Maxim gets
desperate and he definitely is desperate
I mean he's in a must-win situation G4
is not out of the question here folks
mark my words
G4 is a maybe like a you know chaotic
good move
um in a position like this uh I also was
looking at Knight G5
just you know real ideas of sacrificing
somewhere particularly on F7
but uh yeah as you're highlighting there
always seems to be an answer here
there's not just going to be a move you
produce out of nowhere as white and it
just blindsides Lavon ronian and wins
this game all of a sudden you're down
three minutes and I see moves like Queen
C2 I see moves like Rook A1 coming in as
soon as black Shores up this King side
situation and the pressure on E6 look
for Queen C2 and Rook A1 and White's
just going to be in big trouble yeah
Black's not gonna sit on the save file
forever he's actually gonna transform it
into something tangible you called it
there's that Knight G5 move trying his
best uh to add some oil to the fire but
I think Knight f8 might come very close
to extinguishing that fire the D4 Pawn
also becomes a serious weakness a
possibility of going to be three
it has to be reckoned with now the
Armageddon game will start as this game
is going we will bring you that game
when it begins we will update you on
what the players are bidding they are
currently in the bidding process mind
you that in the Armageddon both sides
bid the time that they are willing to
accept the side with the lower bid gets
the black pieces and whatever they bid
the side that bid the higher number gets
the white pieces and always gets 15
minutes and there's no increment in
Armageddon I always remind people of
this
it's a completely different game of mine
yeah I think everyone watching needs to
be reminded of it and I think there
needs to be a private seminar for all
the players as well so that they're
reminded of this because uh it's the
worst feeling when you think time should
be added to your Vlog where's my two
seconds the first time you happen to
notice it is always when you have four
seconds on the clock like it's you never
notice that when you have 11 12 minutes
nope you'll you'll figure that out when
it's exactly it's this house we have our
we have our uh PTSD from that that's for
sure
yeah well all's well that ends well
Knight Fate by Lavon trying to make sure
White's attack doesn't end well I guess
we should show why Knight takes F7
doesn't work come on I mean which I
actually haven't yet totally determined
myself yeah I guess we should show yeah
come on why don't you show us come on
yeah you you take it wait he played it
just as I was making them
he literally made the move as I was
making it and I was gonna say here white
has Perpetual but does he have more than
that
and the interesting thing is we've now
outsourced our work so that might seem
Lavon of rhodian and maximum they can
show us the variation so pay attention
yeah you asked them to do it yep guys
thank you very much and and obviously
crucial to remember is that a draw is
insufficient for uh Maxine said that's
it I think Oman I don't see a single way
for I why can't create even a single
made thread you can go rookie five but
then even
oh yeah H4 but against against both
moves H6 and King H7 only leads that's
right yeah so probably already a losing
position for white Maxim should try H4
Mike seems to try H4 yeah I was thinking
about something like
um maybe if you pull up an analysis
board so like H4 I do want to play H5
and queen F5 so at least I have a threat
um and if you play H6 in response then
it's like
something about H5 Queen F5 check and
Bishop takes H6 yep that you know it
gets a little muddy there with Rook E6
coming so I was thinking that's that's
an idea but you know how are you playing
this position Dania are you going all
out and willing to lose this game some
players just have a different
perspective on that I I don't see a
reason why not but this is an unrated
game as I've said previously in the
World Cup which is the most high profile
knockout tournament there's rating
considerations if you you don't want to
do something stupid and lose a classical
game especially if you're the underdog
and you're gaining rating from a draw
here there's no rating on the table you
literally would rather give up your
queen than make a draw and we're gonna
see Maxine doing something similar B3
trying to distract the queen from C6 now
in the meantime we have news on the nepo
front Jan has bid 12 minutes Peter
svidler has been 11 minutes that means
that Fiddler will have the black pieces
and draw odds with 11 minutes on the
clock Amman that scares me you're four
minutes down against nepo to start the
game
that's yeah that's gonna be a tough one
for Peter
yeah usually you're down four minutes to
Napo four minutes into the game but here
you know you just start with it so
you've uh you've already got yourself in
a hole but I will say with all draws in
the match you can make a case that look
it has been the result today and uh if
it continues to be that way obviously
you'd rather have those black pieces so
that Armageddon goes your way
yeah and and for John you know you know
he's going to put pressure on the clock
he's going to have to choose an
open-ended opening
um not like a rue Lopez that quickly
Fizzles out into something clearly
defined that's exactly what siddler
wants so I'm expecting one C4 from Jan I
don't think he's gonna play E4 something
tells me he's gonna play with Peter
svidler just played
uh himself in their final quick draw
with the white pieces we'll see yeah
that's right
that's right so that'll be uh that'll be
a really interesting match I I found it
uh also uh of note that they bid 12 and
11 minutes and I just think that the
more Savvy uh Armageddon bidders tend to
be like 11 58 you know but these guys
are 12 11 whatever give me whatever
color works out round number it's like
those Jeopardy Jeopardy final you know
the Final Jeopardy Wagers like 50 60
676 dollars because if I answer
correctly then I'm gonna be three
dollars away from number two these
players give me 11 12 minutes just let's
let's start the game let's get let's
start the game exactly exactly let's get
this game underway and speaking about uh
getting something underway how about the
attacks seem needs to get his move
underway doesn't he I don't think he
sees a move no I I don't well I don't
think he sees one and I don't think
there is one
um the obviously guys that the engine is
going to be giving
you know equal like it's going to be
giving 0.00 because there's a Perpetual
but if you look at the scores two to one
beside their names there
that's not available for for Maxime to
choose so he has to pick something that
the engine probably will not like in
order to play this game
got it yeah I mean
there is still a possibility to blunder
Bishop D7 Queen takes D5 and queen H5
made
so that's why I was lobbying so heavily
for Lavon to play H6 instead he tries to
solve his problems more directly with
rookie 8 and Amman once the Rooks are
off the board you're basically not
risking getting checkmated and I think
this one is coming to an end pretty
pretty darn quickly
yep
I agree with that here I don't think you
want to get into
uh Bishop takes E8 Queen D5 so yeah
looks like Levon is solid here Dania
he is indeed he's got plenty of time on
the clock and we will of course keep you
posted on the results of this game but
as we get ready for the Armageddon one
more quick recap of Armageddon rules
Peter Spindler will have the black
pieces he starts with 11 minutes nepo
starts with 15 minutes but if the game
ends in a draw that is tantamount to
victory for the side with the black
pieces that is why an Armageddon game
always produces a decisive result so if
the game is drawn black wins the players
are ready your seat belts need to be
firmly and tightly fastened because I
have a feeling that we are in for a
crazy Armageddon game I'm on that's not
always the case Navara Adams that was
pretty damn one-sided so we've seen all
sorts of Armageddon games that's right
no it could be anything which is why
we're going to make sure to tune in and
yeah that is a beautiful call from you
buddy that C4 move you knew was gonna
come out and well there's a few things
to keep keep in mind for this game the
time like we've been talking about that
the whole match with four minutes less
if you think about all the games that
have happened so far svidler would be
more than flagged in in most of them if
you take away four minutes
um yeah and also there's no increment so
hey it's not going up at all with the
two second America man the positions in
which nepo would offer a draw rook and
three versus rook in three he is
flagging him in this situation now why
is nepo doing all of this stuff with his
pawns he's trying to avoid a grunfels
Peter Spiller one of the foremost
experts in the grunfeld and so nepo
trying to get something a little bit
more fresh this is already a pretty wild
position I think it's still Theory E5
what's happening
this looks fresh enough I will say
Bishop B4 checks Fiddler still seems to
be in his preparation
oh Queen E7
wow
defending everything at once again it's
like Atlas holding the world on his
shoulders yeah and I wonder what
happened so where I'm wondering where
the Knight goes and it looks like if
white goes Bishop E2 like just trying to
break the pin that that Pawn's kind of a
goner after Knight G4
Bishop P2 yeah Knight G4 and if you lose
this Pawn you could end up being
seriously worse I think the main
drawback of black setup Amman is that
you've played the move G6 and your
Bishop is nowhere near its rightful
fianchetto spot so in the long run if
you Castle kingside you're gonna have to
deal with the weaknesses on the dark
squares
yeah and what I'm looking at the move
Bishop D3 because I'm saying whatever
black does
Knight G4 D6 I'm gonna Castle I don't
care what it is and if you ever take my
e-pawn I don't care what it is I'm gonna
take it I'm gonna bring my Rook to E1 so
this is certainly an interesting
decision because 94 jumps out at you but
then you gotta look at A3
yeah 94 A3 I think loses a piece if we
pull up an analysis board real faster I
can show how A3 you have to keep the pin
going but after Queen A5 B4 and you
might say oh let me go Knight C3 counter
attack white screen but remember at the
end of the line you just end up losing
the Knight on D1 so that's out of the
question let's hope svidler doesn't
blunder like that we try to stay
objective as commentators but the last
thing you want you know is an early
blunder to decide the game
no doubt where should the Knight go G4
or do you go back to E7 or the queen
what I was thinking H5
um and that somehow somehow H5 could be
really annoying for a white Bishop on E2
or D3 jumping in the F4 square and if
you make white spend more time
developing with G3 I think that's kind
of what you want meanwhile the rest of
your pieces are coming up D6 Knight C6
and the other thing about Knight H5 is
you can always jump back to G7 and get
into the game on F5 or E6 if necessary
listen Prague says Tanya hyping up a
standard line
um I don't know what theory of books
you've been reading but I actually am
totally unfamiliar with this line
there's probably our share of mvl
aronian games from 2016 right nothing is
unexplored territory but I think this is
sufficiently fresh to make a foremost
grundfeld expert think so from a Time
perspective it's a good choice by now
but look at that move by Peter Castle's
King side
it's cold-blooded
um this uh this move with rookie eight
and after Bishop E2 follow the arrows
everyone because D3 is going to pin that
Bishop
indeed and by the way the Iranian game
is about to end any second now Lavon is
literally up a full piece now let's pan
out back to that game to catch the final
two or three moves I think Malikov is
going to resign any second now
and yeah
will be the end of things and when you
said it was a full piece you weren't
kidding no literally yeah
unfortunately this is done there's uh
there's nothing you can do here as white
um I I mean at this point I'm not even
sure that I would offer a draw as black
just to win the match you know that
would be very generous yep although
repeating moves could be a signal that I
don't think montlickov is going to
decline a repetition here no but Lavon
is going for the win Queen he won yeah
he's not sure why he's not resigning
right I mean you don't have winning
chances in this position he's going to
resign after that move there it is for
sure
we congratulate Levon aronian who wins
that clutch third game and we switch
back immediately to our Armageddon game
can't miss any action here and oh the
Knight did go to H5 okay I kind of like
the night there I think this Knight F4
thing is annoying
um but white might want to deal with it
with saying okay rookie won and as long
as the night doesn't get there for my
Rook gets to E1 I always have Bishop F1
to drop back to
um I'm also looking at the pawns and I
know we're not focused on it but let's
just remember to keep count because
black does have all their Pawns yeah and
white has only seven
and white cannot afford just to drop the
E5 part right you can't just say ah I
don't really need that pawn either I
actually think that the battle is going
to revolve largely around this E5 Pawn
Ken black win it can black at the very
least get it off the board before you
know White's got a queen on H6 and a
knight on G5 that's right yeah it's a
really dangerous idea the thing that I
like about Black's position is to move
Rook E8 and queen f8 could happen in one
move
um which was maybe a useful Square so I
don't know I would have started with
rookie eight do you think that he was
concerned about C5 I think he was
concerned about C5 because it doesn't
threaten anything directly but it keeps
the queen jailed locked out of the king
side and I think Peter trying to take a
more cautious route I'm curious what
he's planning against rookie one uh I
think it's just D6 I think he wants to
liquidate the center and that position
is going to be a heck of a lot easier to
play even if you know he's lost his
objective Edge
yeah no that's a great way to put it the
move C5 is just one of the moves you
don't want to deal with you'd rather be
on the other side of that pawn and you
know they have those expressions the
threats stronger than the execution I've
always enjoyed the the quote uh the move
doesn't threaten anything but it
threatens to threaten right it's a
second order threat yeah there's nothing
more dangerous than being a threat being
threatened
no that's actually this threats being
threatened are some of the cool it's
just one of the great Concepts in chess
just the idea that uh complexity exists
in layers okay we actually have D6 on
the board there's a trade in nepo now
has to focus on winning this Pawn back
ASAP and getting a playable position
right you can't just trade all of the
pieces Fiddler still has seven and a
half minutes on the clock that's a lot
done a great job so far
yeah and the time difference is actually
right on money four minutes so uh the
time difference being maintained which
is usually a good sign for nepo like I
think you're happy in general when
you're playing Armageddon if you're
still up that four minutes but most of
you have way less time yeah Mission
success you want to maintain it up to
four minutes to zero yeah exactly and
nepo's happy with this now the big
question I'm on do you I don't think
he's going to take on C6 just yet
because after Queen takes C6 you've
given up your biggest asset and you
might not even win the pawn back because
C4 is going to be hanging
and then the question is what do you do
because I look that you can talk about
get the position of the clock whatever I
think Fiddler has just acquitted himself
really well I think he's got a great
opening for an Armageddon game I think
it's been fantastic so far Spindler
should be very very happy with how this
match has gone
not to raise the alarm bells for nepo
fans too quickly but with the center
being wide open I always draw attention
to that I'm on because when the center
is open there is a high probability of
trades right just by definition so nepo
has to trade very carefully to make sure
that he's actually keeping pieces on the
board as I said earlier I was thinking
maybe you should start with C5 but if
you do no problemo the queen just swings
over to F6 and the light skirt Bishop
has plenty of prospects yeah now you can
see why nepo is taking a chunk of time
here
indeed he it's not about maintaining the
time Edge he needs to find something
that actually makes this playable and I
love the I love the comments that are
being brought up on screen it's like
Spindler playing so well and it's like
he just doesn't care about my fantasy
bracket at all
no no he does busted yeah he wants to
bust it and you know it just reminds us
that everyone was betting on John de
palmishi in fantasy right so this was
like a 98 uh Community pick now Bishop
D5 I I wanted to point out the Knight
can drop back but why didn't it move to
F4 I thought Knight F4 was just like bad
for white smidler's same idea but a
different move
totally agree at Knight F4 versus F6
seems like a no-brainer to me
if Knight takes D5 what is nepo cooking
up here is it Knight B5
no okay here's gonna be Queen takes and
at least we can understand there's I
mean there's a nice Cheapo that maybe
you could throw throw on the board uh
for us here Knight takes D5 please
[Music]
um
yeah Queen takes a nice little puzzle
Rush moment for everybody
but smiddler he takes on D5
he's not gonna play Queen takes d55 is
this one
indeed by the way just really really
quickly if he had gone C6 nepo prepared
C5 dislodging the queen and taking the
Knight so svidler navigating the
Minefield six and a half minutes on the
clock
how does he try to get to the spawn does
he plays C6 does he played Bishop E6
Bishop P6 might be a takeout move
Bishop E6 yeah he might do that
that's a good point
is he gonna swing like Queen H4 Knight
G5 I think about that to get a little uh
a little dangerous it could get dicey
The Rook coming to D1 I don't like
svidler's decision to drop the Knight
back to F6 after Knight F4 I think he
was solidly better now you get the sense
that Napo suddenly is brought us pieces
out from the dead Spindler with five and
a half minutes as we're speaking
the next three or four moves are going
to be absolutely critical
yeah that's a a great point this Pawn on
D5 Bishop B6 I mean nepo has surely seen
this we see that time Advantage it is
still exactly four minutes so definitely
uh I think netball can't be unhappy with
how that's going the position though is
starting to liquidate it's progressing
Bishop E6 is a really really key move
using the pin and he's basically picking
up that deep on so what does nepo have
in exchange because he's losing the pawn
is it fair to say I'm on the nepo that D
takes E6 is what nepo would have played
in a classical game but it's out of the
question here because drawing that Rook
end game is way too easy am I correct in
saying that yeah yeah so that is
Queen H4 and Knight G5 is really the
only way uh to creating side activity
but let's forecast these moves really
really quickly if Queen H4 Bishop D5
Knight G5 H5
a lot of people here would be tempted by
this moving one but after Queen F4 white
can basically resign you don't just try
always the black king that easily no
chess is a fair game and uh any
Checkmate attack is usually prepared uh
you know it's it's worked for so
what is going on after Bishop E6 so if
it's not Queen H4 do we have other ideas
than Queen H4 because Queen to H4 looks
like speculation to me and maybe a
last-ditch move what about Rook 81 no
still Bishop takes C5 yeah and C6 Queen
H4 is on the board let's swing back to
the live position yep Queen H4 has been
played and swindler immediately takes on
D5 this is nepo's idea he starts with
Rook 81. right
um do you just Shore things up and play
C6 here
um just like the major 594
a night up six you know the interesting
thing about uh position let's say like
that is sometimes this might be again
the way to play in a different situation
but if the best you're doing is like
winning a pawn back or something that's
not enough
I know it sounds crazy but even the move
F6 uh is in play here I think stopping
this Knight g594 Knight f600 I agree
that the point of putting that on F6 is
not to take on D5 but yeah maybe you can
create some tactical chances based on
that maybe then swing the queen back to
D4 F6 is on the board
great move by Peter yeah I think that's
a really classy move because to do F6
really shows that he appreciates the
danger of Knight G5 uh even the
Practical danger to find time for this
move right now after Rook D1 when The
Bishop's a little bit loose I think
that's uh it's a really really key move
for swiddler and his next move is C6
Dania yeah once he plays C6 rookie eight
you know he's King G7 it's unbreakable
as this position looks like then it
comes out at the time yeah at this point
the evaluation is not in question I mean
this is much better for black no
compensation zero compensation for the
pawn and a monster Bishop on D5
oh my land something's in the air ladies
and gentlemen and nepo has to find a way
to milk to milk every second
offspidler's clock that is his best
chance right now I don't think we're
disputing that
yep H3 at some point I think that move
has to be played so I don't mind the the
the move H3 the other thing that it does
maybe not a main idea but I like it
Knight H2 Knight G4
um you know using the dark squares after
F6 that's definitely where
you want to be I think Mondo Peter
taking 30 seconds on a move like C6
he I feel like he's got to cut that
thinking time down
if nepo can get him below three minutes
that's when you start getting really
concerned C6 is on the board
and you are on a roll Knight H2 trying
to induce H5 which would create a
weakness on G6
it's on the board
yeah H5
that was so tricky
yep he's doing things well the Knight on
E3 is fantastic yes
man if you have to predict a result
right now do you think Spiller pulls it
out
I'm gonna say I I think the time
pressure yeah decides it and nepo just
somehow somehow
I feel like it all depends on whether
nepo can keep the Queens on the board so
far he's been doing a phenomenal job of
it I agree I'm on svidler he's just
dipping on the clock he's down to three
and a half minutes this is an Armageddon
game smidler wins the match with the
draw yeah but can he stay afloat on the
clock and avoid a blunder
he's really playing
so well and he hasn't even at this point
the reason that the engine is creeping
closer to the middle of the board 0.00
is because you might lose that deep Pawn
Knight takes D5 and whatever but we have
to remember that's not an option for
white to take so don't think that
Fiddler is necessarily blundering away
right like exact that's such a good
explanation
this is him playing really well actually
yeah because he he uses he's got all the
leverage in the position they draw a
stand to mount to a loss so take the
eval with a grain of salt unless the
eval goes in White's favor uh you know
civil is doing fine B5 an excellent move
by Young can black take on B5 can you
get away with that
that's uh that's a great question that
I'm happy not to answer
Oh My Lens there's a crazy line that I'm
trying to calculate I won't make the
moves on the board because Fiddler is
too low on the clock let's stick to the
current game the decision here is
between C5 and CB in my opinion
indeed and I feel like if you're between
those two moves you should probably take
yep and you should do it fast two and a
half minutes two and a half minutes a
month it's still four minutes that's
been the time difference
I think he can do it I I think he can
play C takes P5 and Knight takes Bishop
complications seem like they are okay
for black
five what up what a nerves of Steel move
by Peter
but now he's in trouble yeah look how
easy it is to play Queen A4 though a7s
lose B6 is probably no this is looking
bad Bishop F7 though holding on for dear
life
Fiddler needs to liquidate it's not
enough to just hey you play Move I play
move things need to disappear from the
chessboard but he's not doing it and now
he's down to two minutes I'm on even if
you can consider a rook Knight and three
against Rook bishop and three he's going
to flag Peter Exactly if Peter had has
anything below two minutes on the clock
let's let's be realistic
yep six minutes to two and we talked
about that four minutes it's kind of
happening that it's gonna be like four
to zero soon this is honestly so
impressive by Yan so few people I'm on
he and he's making it look easy keeping
pieces on the board he was down a pawn
with worst place pieces the H3 Knight H2
idea was amazing and on the strength of
that he's gotten Peter down to a minute
45. this one is going down the toilet I
think for repeat swity
it definitely looks like it I need moves
they need to be quicker more decisive
Rook f8 something yeah unfortunately it
doesn't matter what move he produces
here it's too slow because it's been 45
seconds no it only has a minute and a
half no but he knows there's no
increment but this is
this is that unless he finds among some
way uh to mount a drawing counter-attack
against White's King but that seems so
unlikely nepoken
uh can keep himself relatively safe
especially at night on E3 the hero of
the game it really is a super strong
piece and it looks way too cold
Queen A2 interestingly that can be
played I think he did yeah that's that's
not a nepo face of like okay yeah in
stride part of the calculation
definitely did miss that
[Music]
um
big difference the king is so safe on H2
and the king is so unsafe on G7 you
basically need the queen to stay in
contact with the bishop to avoid
Shenanigans of the queen E6 variety
which means that spiedler just doesn't
have the leverage to like force anything
against White's King
Queen takes B6 Rook takes F2 is not out
of the question by the way
wow is that just a safety first kind of
move oh what a move Aman Rook takes F2
now Rook takes F7 is terrible because
that leads to a draw black has three
pawns for the night there
yeah that's that's very interesting
actually super tricky Knight F5 though
and you start to get a little nervous
here is black one minute and five
seconds still a four minute time
difference what a move rookie too not
concerned at all the queen on A2 look at
the Geometry The Rook the bishop
everything Knight F5 you go King H7 that
Queen
it was on E7 in the opening it's a hero
now
can Jan continue to complicate the game
he's down two pawns at this point and
the B Pawn is ready to move forward
ooh
interesting decision I don't hate it but
I I think it's objectively wrong
um and I think the reason look there's a
reason he did that Peter is saying I
want an easy position to play I want to
play B4 I want to play B3 I want to have
it protected I want to pre-move to my
draw it's and and people should not look
at the Evo or this is a hundred percent
understandable decision this might be a
very good decision you know what hurts
Yan here is the fact that his King is
now permanently unsafe there's always a
check here there's always a check here
so that circumscribes the power of the
White Queen to create threats and that's
why nepo keeps it on this diagonal
okay but here is what whenever I have
here's the issue I have with this uh
idea from svidler yes you've got this
but you're you don't have any threats
you can't do anything actively and won't
your time just disappear slowly well but
Queen E5 check would have forced the
trade of Queens leaving black with two
pawns for the exchange I thought Peter
should have considered that yeah
no longer he agrees with you that was
bad that was a missed missed opportunity
there for Peter to make this even easier
to play
okay moves like Bishop C4 they seem
weird to me why not leave the bishman F7
and go King G6
exactly you have to commit because I
think you're trying to do too much as
black here back to F7 see four seconds
right there he's spending five six
everything second is golden here and oh
Peter's way too slow what is he and this
is this is the thing I think that he
might be considering team E4
I swear I think he's considering King E4
and he's if he was yeah you got you
can't be falling into this there's no
Queen E5 so tricky well Queen E5 here's
the thing Queen E5 is now a huge threat
if Peter can get the Queens off the
board in this version
then the position becomes easier to
remove King F4 this is an attempt to
force the draw with Queen G3 a huge
threat you can check on C7 Holy Queen E5
Queen takes C4 check
no and King E3 and is there a draw there
because it's oh my God Queen A1 but
Queen F1 holy smokes but I'm on after
Queen C7 King F5 the the problem that
Jan is butting up against right now is
how do you stop the queen trade with
Black's King close enough to basically
promote the pawn this is going to be a
flag Fest I have a feeling that Smither
is gonna like have a queen on the board
yeah ladies and gentlemen we are in for
a wild ride to finish this game
yep
oh my goodness this is uh honestly I
would say somebody a little bit faster
than Fiddler more Savvy I would probably
say like I even favor his chances with
uh with the black people totally 22
seconds
Legend in his own right needs to show us
that Mouse feed and can he keep up King
E2 was the move
oh we went the wrong way King E2 Bishop
D3 Bishop D3 though
King C1 King C2 the bishop and the queen
shelter the black king from the lateral
checks by The Rook but the problem is
you're sheltered oh what else that's it
all right you're just sitting there
you're sitting there with Queen E5 a
huge threat King H1 yes King H1 I think
Rook A6 so tricky made on A1 is
threatened
smidler's a hero for defending this but
he's down to 13 seconds
out Queen F1 you could just like you
kind of Shuffle like spy everything
smidler has that smile he knows exactly
what's about to happen he's down to 10
seconds yeah this is over a heartbreaker
for Mr svidler
yeah you guys can see if Queen H3 Queen
takes G2 that's his idea but I think
everyone knows even though the eval bar
is 0.00 it's just not gonna happen
there's a maiden one threat it doesn't
matter it is a moot point
and John nepom Yoshi pulls it out
oh my goodness one more minute on
Peter's clock this would have been a
draw
and Peter didn't make any blunders
notice how that eval bar never ever went
past halfway he played so well
he played an unbelievable match against
Dion all throughout he was on equal
terms he was drawing from a position of
strength especially with the black
pieces and in the Armageddon he
outplayed janapamnushi The Exchange sack
was an incredible practical decision I
think we can say in retrospect but I'm
on a five seconds here 10 seconds there
a slightly more accurate move here and
we might be talking about perhaps the
biggest upset of the cgc and instead
Jana probably pulls through once again
there was a moment where he could have
actually gone
and maybe this is a moot point but I
think King E2 would have led to a
winning position white has no checks
yeah it's a really strange concept but
um yeah there's just nothing that white
can do in that position everything's
defended E6 traps covered F6 pawns
defended uh the queen no checks from G1
it's like then black can really start
playing maybe the move B2 soon
yeah I mean B2 Queen G3 probably Queenie
one
probably Queen B1 Beyond keeps the
pieces on the board maybe he still would
have won but no Queen Chief Queen G3 and
Queenie one as you're saying exactly
yeah that oh my God that threat is
actually deciding
that would have won on the spot Spiller
would have won this game if you want
King E2 that's amazing yeah gives the
queen real estate and gives it a chance
to check on F2 that is how close he came
to to knocking out nepo in the
Armageddon
holy smokes I don't know how much to be
don't know how much of a discussion we
want this to be but King E2
maybe the The Rook wants to go down to
like E7 so that you're threatening uh
rookie seven check after Queenie one
that's like how how you want to be
tricky
um in a situation like this right if
you're nepo and knowing nepo not a doubt
in my mind he would play this mode he
will find every little way so many
pieces on the board but Queen E3 here at
the very least I think basically forces
uh a queen trade exactly because then
then you'll be able to go Queen G3 Queen
E1 so wow as we're breaking it down guys
I think what we're deducing here is King
E2 with 30 seconds I think he was about
25 27 seconds on the clock Danya that
would have been enough I think for
Fiddler to put it away so unbelievable I
mean the chances that he had there to
draw this game and win the match it was
such a such a close close fight it was
an incredible match ladies and gentlemen
the matches conclude as we review the
scores one final time here Hikaru
Nakamura a smooth victory over David
nemara all smooth sailing levonaronian
wins a critical equal drawn end game in
game three and finishes it off with a
victory in game four and Jana pomdishi
pulls through in the Armageddon in the
most improbable uh Fashions to knock off
Peter's Fiddler we will have Mr nepo in
the studio to share his thoughts on this
roller coaster topsy-turvy match so go
absolutely nowhere we'll have more cgc
coverage and a wrap up for you on the
other side of this short break
foreign
[Music]
the winner of a scintillating match
against Peter svidler Yan thanks for
joining us let's start with the
Armageddon game what are your thoughts
on that game overall and at what point
Did you sort of realize that the clock
was going to be your most important
weapon
oh yeah the clock uh would be my only
only alley in
yeah on I mean only chance well uh to to
begin with uh I should say that uh I was
very very naive uh setting the time I
mean asking for the time like 7 pm
because I'm still badly jet liked after
after Saint Louis
and normally I sleep at this time so I
mean uh I just uh yeah I was really
struggling
and yeah going to to the Armageddon game
I think there is nothing to to be proud
of so when I got this set up like with
an extra Exchange
uh somehow I thought okay maybe there is
a way to to flag reflect teacher somehow
um but then he started to run with his
King and yeah this dude was just
shocking
I mean I had no idea what should I do
like I mean King is uh you know getting
closer and closer and
there is uh yeah
yeah I mean uh getting closer definitely
very nice idea from him yeah because if
I would trade Queen somehow probably it
would be quite
quite an easy just to flag him in case
if I would if I would decide to do this
yeah
um I guess you mentioned the time that
it is for you right now Jan I was going
to ask you about game number four this
is there's this interesting moment we
saw like draw offer and then maybe you
declined it and then the next move you
offered one uh were you content with
playing a you know a bit of a shorter
match in that sense and just getting to
the Armageddon because of the time and
also what went into declining the draw
and then offering it on the next move
I don't know for actually for a second I
think that I will be able to maintain
blockade on D5
uh but after he castled uh well uh I
mean I I quickly I quickly got to the
that probably
um he's just modern in time he had to
play D5 and uh like
remove all the pieces from the board so
maybe uh maybe I I'm the one who should
be precise so
uh there is yeah
I I was slightly slightly worried if uh
at this moment he he would reject the
draw but uh yeah
foreign
you've obviously played Peter a million
times you've played the young players
from your generation in Russia and
Beyond do you think there's something
stylistically different between the way
that Peter plays for example and the way
that uh the players of the younger
generation of disadorov uh gukesh and
all of those other players play so
there's something appreciably different
in their playing Styles in your
experience
it's hard to see uh first of all Peter
is an artist I mean he's like yeah for
him chess is an Argent when it's like
when it's going uh you know and it's
going nice when it's going fancy he
becomes extremely strong like because he
you know sort of like he really enjoys
hair the he likes the process he likes
the game uh she likes it you know quite
a bit and
um
probably
not not the worst idea to play some
boring chess against him yeah so he can
jump around with his pieces and he can't
really trick you or something
so stylistically yeah he's
like he's very very special I would say
he's quite a quite a unique player so
I'm
I really struggle to
to recall anyone anyone like him okay
maybe maybe I am in some way yeah when I
get some nice position I'm really yeah
I'm getting excited yeah like and I
really want to play it well but uh this
is yeah still far from you know
from his uh you know from his style
yeah and you're you're also moving on in
the competition
um whether whether or not you uh
continue is what we're all excited to uh
to find out but how has your experience
been playing these matches so far
they're getting more intense as we
slowly get closer and closer to Toronto
foreign
the first match was I think in Saint
Louis and it was like 8 A.M uh or
something so uh I'm not quite used uh to
playing uh literally and uh yeah this
match was also something special because
of you know
uh schedule and jet lag so yeah it's
it's very intense like uh you know
doesn't that doesn't really matter what
the time is it I mean it's really
intense and uh I'd say better just
outplayed me in uh in most of the games
I only I only had some small chances in
the first game
uh
uh I think I could play G5 instead of uh
Knight F3 and G5 was nearly winning
but besides that uh yeah I mean I always
was like uh trying to to fight for my
life
yeah so the matches are yeah
really really tough and uh probably
closer to the to closer to Toronto yeah
it's
it's getting more and more difficult
is there somebody that you prefer to
face between Arjun and Timur
I would probably you know if both gets
uh you know if both of them you know
they will get you know disqualified so I
just you know just get a free slot yeah
I mean if it really works
so that's uh that's my main you know my
main hope
uh but uh yeah I guess they're all both
like brilliant players and
I think uh I don't know what did Arjun
do today in uh
and the Champions just to uh in the
Champions just tour I'll just uh check
this out later and okay Timor is yeah
known to be one of the like best GMS of
uh you know of his generation yeah and I
also did quite well in Madrid
so
probably it's you know it's more about
me if I'll be able to you know
to sleep more or less normally closer to
the
closer to there this um this match
so I have maybe one more week or
something
yeah exactly
I think I'm out of questions myself and
obviously it's late uh for for Yan after
a long match so I'll hand it back over
to you yeah I think we we will let you
go yeah and there's uh let's see if we
have like maybe one chat if we could
keep you for maybe one more chat
question
um we'll see if there are any good
questions from the chat and then we will
let you take your well-deserved rest
there is a question how nervous were you
toward the end or did you feel
comfortable with the time Advantage were
you certain of the results or at what
point were you certain of the results
uh maybe when he I don't know he somehow
ran with his King to the corner
and I found this queen of one Queen in
one trick and he really got love on time
and at this point I think it was already
practically quite quite difficult for
him to to fight because a gate was like
eight seconds or something and clearly
the position requires some I don't know
foreign
[Music]
that's very insightful Jan we will let
you rest uh good luck against the winner
of Arjun against anymore thank you so
much for joining us for an interview and
congratulations on a great thank you
very much thank you congrats
okay that's a wrap ladies and gentlemen
there are the final scores I'm on it was
a tale of three matches that really had
their own storyline their own narrative
and that's honestly what I love about
the cgc the fact that like you can spin
a storyline out of each individual match
yeah indeed there's a story line there
there's you know other story lines that
evolve and come to fruition as players
advance and uh after today's results
Hikaru Nakamura advances and Jana
pomnishi we just spoke to advances as
well over Peter svidler in group E and
finally in Group H we have Lavon aronian
advancing as well so Danny actually all
the favorites that people expected to
win in the end got there and and did
events one way or another
yeah I mean one way or another by hook
or by crook by time or by crime and as
we look at the overall bracket of 64
. there have been a lot of upsets there
have been a lot of players who have
breasted have blasted and destroyed
basically every bracket in the book I'm
thinking of the guy is a machine he
played yet another impressive match
today against Notre back up to sitarov
beating some amateur named vicious
before he will be facing Anish Gary
that's on the right side of your screen
rajaba very geissy will be played next
week nihal sarin defeating Vladimir
kramnik we've also had players that have
been incredibly smooth I'm Wesley so
lanyard Dominguez they have been
forces to be reckoned with and the
results of their matches have never been
in question so Amon uh before I say the
final words I'll pass it back to you one
more time your thoughts on today overall
and on the cgc thus far
yeah I mean today's matches were really
excited I think we got a little bit of
everything because we had a match that
started off as one that maybe we were
kind of not batting an eye to this
levonne aronian and Maxine matlikov
match and all of a sudden it exploded
with one of the biggest blunders that
we've seen today you know and I'll never
cheer for blenders and chess but I have
to admit as a commentator and as a fan
it does make it pretty exciting that was
the biggest blunder we had today then of
course we had a neck and neck match
where Fiddler was playing out of his
mind I thought that was a really uh
classy nod that nepo gave him in the
interview as well just calling him an
artist and how you know when when things
flow and work well that's when svidler
is at the top of his game and the top of
his game can be above so many players in
the Chess World and finally we had
Hikaru Nakamura with a one-sided Victory
where it looked like he could have
easily had he could have easily won all
three games finished two and a half to
half so like I said Dania it was so nice
to get a little bit of everything today
and it's been a pleasure bringing
everyone the the commentary alongside
yourself
likewise I'm on always a pleasure to
commentate with you and as the day wraps
up there will be more cgc action to come
Arjun Eric dicey will take on two more
our job of next week stay tuned for the
specific time
and the cgc the wheels continue to turn
we continue to get to get closer and
closer to start of November in Toronto
where only eight players will book their
tickets and only one of them will take
home the two hundred thousand dollar
purse but for now ladies and gentlemen
thank you to everybody in the chat chat
was hopping today it always is it really
breathes so much magic into this magical
event thank you to our producer Holland
everybody on our amazingchess.com team
but for now ladies and gentlemen we hope
you have a lovely rest of your Saturday
and a great rest of your weekend from
the chess.com Global Championship Jim
Daniel nerdinski GM I'm on Hamilton
beating you goodbye and a great rest of
your weekend bye
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]